this is Jocko podcast number 75 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening we have shared
the in communicable experience of war
we have felt we still feel the passion
of life to its top in our youth our
hearts were touched by fire that's a
quote from Oliver Wendell Holmes Supreme
Court Judge a lot of people know that
but they may not know Civil War soldier
served with the 20th regiment of
Massachusetts Volunteer Infantry saw
action all over the place Peninsula
Campaign the wilderness he was wounded
at the Battle of balls Bluff also
wounded and Antietam and also wounded at
the Battle of Chancellorsville so I
think it's safe to say that he knew and
understood war and that quote right
there is from the beginning of another
book about another man that new war
major dick winters now we've covered
dick winters before his book on this
podcast number 17 beyond band of
brothers great book lots of lessons
learned but there's another book which
is called the conversations with major
dick winters life lessons from the
commander of the band of brothers and
it's written by a guy named Colonel Cole
C King seed who was friend dick winners
and who actually was the co-author
behind that book beyond band of brothers
so what's cool about this book is it
really parses out some lessons about
leadership in a conversational manner
with dick winners the things have you
thought and the blessings that he
learned which I mean when you get an
opportunity to learn from someone like
this you know what I do I just be quiet
I listen and I learn or in this case I
read and I learned so this is also the
guy if you haven't seen this series on
HBO Band of Brothers just go stop and
just go watch it it's I don't know what
it is like 12 to 12 episodes they're all
awesome if we ask me all the time what's
realistic war movies that one Band of
Brothers and then the Pacific all both
HBO series they're both phenomenal and I
recommend you watch it you'll learn a
lot about dick winters on that and then
the guy that plays dick winters does a
great job and the way they tell the
story and the realism and all that it's
just an awesome series but here we can
learn not interpreted through a movie
but actually from the man as you spoke
it so here we go taking it back to the
book right now from dick winters d-day
was my first time in combat so right
there let's just talk about that for a
second your first time in combat what's
your mission d-day one of the largest
military operations of all time that's
your first day in combat get some back
to the book I was mentally prepared and
felt that I had done everything
necessary to prepare myself for this
precise moment and you never know if you
will measure up as a leader until the
minute arrives when you face the enemy
for the first time baptism by fire is a
soldier sacrament there is always doubt
hopefully in combat you perform as you
train so I can't imagine that baptism by
fire
d-day again get get some sense of
another good movie Saving Private Ryan
the opening scene of that is the same
thing
that's that's one of the most intense
parts of a movie ever is the d-day when
they're hitting the beaches it's crazy
to watch but watch it because it'll give
you a feeling for what Nick winters is
talking about just imagine all these
preparations that you do you're getting
ready and guess what
here it comes little mission called
d-day now they all BAM that was their
initial operation was during d-day but
then they fought all over the place and
again we cover this in in beyond band of
brothers but one of the most intense
parts of their campaign was at Bastogne
so even though d-day was hard things
didn't get easier once d-day was
complete as much as I'm saying oh yeah
d-day was crazy guess what it wasn't
even the hardest part for them
mmm things got worse back to the book
most of the soldiers and Easy Company
also felt that Bastogne was the most
challenging month of the war
Staff Sergeant bill Guarnere later
claimed that he had been scared before
but he was absolutely petrified at
Bastogne from my perspective
Bastogne was the most miserable place
I've been in my life I was wet through
and through and naturally being a
paratrooper I didn't have a change of
clothes
no blanket nothing and it was a cold son
of a gun
things were all snafued walking around
in the black of night not knowing where
we were exactly where everybody else was
houses burning civilians crying wringing
your hands and behind every bush a
perspective enemy we took our greatest
number of casualties during that
campaign Easy Company was never the same
after Bastogne we lost so many because
we lost so many veterans who had fought
in Normandy and Holland Joe Toye bill
Guarnere buck Compton Don who blur and
many others so this is this is where I
started thinking okay leadership lesson
learned right here I operated the
battalion command post that was situated
approximately
seventy-five yards from the main line of
resistance you might not think 75 yards
is consequential but it gave me the
opportunity to think things through and
divorce myself from the chaos
surrounding the front line and to make
calm rational decisions under pressure
that is the toughest challenge for any
leader so obviously we're talking about
the attachment here and I've talked
about the fact that in order to detach
you can move off the line like six
inches I'm not kidding in a smaller
group you know in a co person he's
talking about a battalion so they got
hundreds of guys so 75 yards is more
appropriate but if you're running a
smaller unit like one company or maybe a
platoon you got thirty forty guys if you
move back off that firing line six
inches a foot maybe you know maybe three
feet or six feet you just step back and
you get yourself out of that firefight
where you can look around that's what
you're going to be able to do you're
going to be able to detach yourself from
the chaos and then mayhem and make calm
rational decisions under pressure
yeah that's such a big deal like where
when you do that when you detach and
then you can you know you have a clearer
vision and a lot of times the answer or
solution to some big problem is just so
simple remember that story you're
telling at the muster where you know
your your guys had an injured man yeah
so he could participate but when to come
along so you watch from the outside and
he's like why don't they just would you
step back in few laughs yeah why don't
they why don't they get online and
people left and whatever the call was so
the story is there was a guy that
actually he was a delta platoon
commander into you bruiser he took over
my position he took over the to you
bruiser commander yeah and then I was
running the training so once I was
running the training you know now I was
overall making things happen and he was
going through the training a different
block of training and he broke his neck
broke his neck and thank God he didn't
hurt his spinal cord but he broke a
vertebrae in his neck so he had to wear
one of those big crazy neck braces and
he couldn't actually do the physical
training wasn't allowed to barely wait
for a certain amount of time
but you know luckily he was able to keep
his job because he was very experienced
and so we were going through the land
warfare portion of training and I said
hey man you know I know you can't
participate but come out with me you
know come out and check it out and you
know you can see your guys you can watch
how they perform and you can you know
teach them some stuff and learn from
from what happens so cool he comes out
and he's actually one of my you know one
of my best friends so of course we
shouldn't hang out anyways Dreamz is all
about so you know of course we has a
chance to come out and hang out with me
the desert for a few weeks it's going to
do it so we we get out there and and you
know you've heard the stories about the
training that I ran it was really hard
and evil and crazy psychotic and we're
doing that you know we got we in that
case we had these really high speed
laser laser tag system and you've got
guys pinned down you got explosions
going off you got just total mayhem
going on and his guys kind of froze up
and they're all pinned down in this
little sort of ravine valley type thing
and I got guys I got my guys my opposing
force so the seals that are pretending
to be bad guys pretending to be moves
they're all up in the mountains shooting
down on them and killing everyone and
his guys there's leadership is just kind
of frozen and they're sitting there not
doing anything and you know he said to
me hey can I help them and I kind of
thought about it from it I go yeah go
ahead yeah go give him you know tell him
what to do give a prompt any and he just
you know goes down to the leader one of
the leaders and says hey get on line and
peel left and so the guy looks at him
and what does get on line mean just it's
an organizational movement where all
your troops are pointed in all different
directions just boom you take contact
right on line and that means everyone is
going to basically face in that
direction if you get a couple guys that
are doing rear security a couple guys
are doing flank security but everyone is
now oriented in the same direction and
in the next call that comes is peel left
boom and they're all gonna start moving
you know in a direction that's going to
get them out of this immediate threat so
he tells he kind of says the guy hey get
on line peel left so the guy looks at
him and he just yells out get on line
peel left and then everyone repeats that
command and then everyone does it and
within a minute they're they're home
free it literally took
like one minute once I made a decision
yes so and then so they get out of there
and he looks at me and he goes he goes a
pan it's so easy when you're way up here
now way up here to put it in perspective
was or feet behind these guys that's all
it was it wasn't like we were up on some
mountaintop yeah an incredible view no
we were we were there we were standing
next to the guys and we were a little
too elevated because they're laying down
and we're standing up but it's it was
not inconceivable that you wouldn't have
the same perspective if you just step
back and maybe you shuffled over a
little bit and he says it's so easy when
when you're up here mm-hmm
and I said bro you remember when we went
through training and he says yeah and I
said it was always like this for me and
it was I was I would always just put
myself back just enough to be able to
see what the solution is yeah so yes
this detachment that he's talking about
and again in a battalion situation where
you're going 75 yards and a head in a
business situation you know I actually
see people do this you're in a you're in
a meeting and there's everyone around
them around the table and there's some
problem that can't be solved you
literally step up and get step away from
the table I just step back get away from
the group they're all mobbed up and
group think everyone's going down the
same trail they're thinking about the
same stuff and there's no new ideas
because they're all right there and
there's a vortex step away from the
table yeah it's same thing like step
step away from your computer you know
you get to some point where you're just
you don't know where to go with some of
you looking for some kind of a solution
to a problem you just step back do that
back see more yeah
yeah and writing a lot of times they'll
suggest just skip to the end
don't worry about like just go to the
end how do you want to end and then
it'll kind of open your mind up it'll
it'll make you sort of forget about this
problem right in front of you you know
ya can give you kind of an overall view
towards the solution that you know can
be found yeah even in an argument with
your wife or something like oh yeah well
for sure that's a big one for sure
because when you yeah you definitely
need to do it they're entrenched you
don't need to get insurance and don't do
that
alright and this part has been covered
before on multiple occasions you know
what we're going to do cover it again
little piece about discipline I did have
a routine a routine that was instilled
into me by Colonel sink at Toccoa
Colonel sink insisted that officers
always shave in the morning regardless
of the situation he would say you shave
every morning for the troops and if you
want to shave every evening for the
women that's up to you
I followed his orders because I realized
that I had to set the proper example for
the men I needed to get their attention
let them all know that I intended to be
around for a while and that the
situation was not as bad as they might
think I remember before 2nd battalion
attacked Foy I had awakened early and
shaved before I ate breakfast I later
discovered that I had cut my face in
multiple places and Colonel sink came up
to check on the battalions readiness
before the attack commenced he took one
look at me and smiled I realized that he
was laughing at me for shaving on that
bitterly cold morning in hindsight
shaving at zero dark thirty and freezing
temperatures was pretty ridiculous I so
you know we talked about this all time
gotta shave got to maintain unmitigated
daily discipline in all things but
what's cool but what I the reason I want
to go over this again is because look at
what he's doing psychologically to the
Troops he's saying I know I had to set
an example I needed to get their
attention and make them realize I can't
work over here for a while and you know
what I was gonna do it daily this is no
big deal oh you're worried about this
stuff I'm still shaving over here I'm
still waking up at zero four hundred
shaving and and you're worried about
this stuff doesn't work we're good to go
and you need to maintain the same
discipline so that leading by example
clearly is a big deal right there and
maintaining that routine maintaining
that discipline
now speaking of discipline back to the
book regardless of how disciplined an
outfit is too much time on your hands
too little activity and too much alcohol
make a volatile combination so this book
skips around a little bit but I put this
in here because this is this is actually
talking about when they were done
fighting and now everyone was kind of
idle he had some idle people on their
hands but it related a discipline so I
wanted to lock it in a little bit back
to the book the battalion was no longer
a combat unit but a garrison outfit it
was more important to keep the troops
gainfully employed to prevent boredom
and monotony that would lead to a
breakdown in discipline and when that
occurs soldiers get careless
consequently the first thing we
organised were calisthenics and athletic
programs you know I always joke about
you know when people say they have some
kind of problem and I'm oh do burpees
right hey you know what a good solution
to all problems are calisthenics can
start doing calisthenics I like that I
like that attitude
well I vividly recall this is this is
another reason why I put this in I
vividly recall watching the men stripped
to their waist or only wearing their
shorts as they played baseball the sight
of all those scars made me conscious of
the fact that only a handful of men in
the battalion have been lucky enough to
make it through all four campaigns
without at least one the scar some men
had two three or even four scars on
their chest back arms or legs keep in
mind that this was after the war so I
was looking only at men who were not
seriously wounded next we set up rifle
ranges and sharpened our marksmanship
close order drill and trooper views were
once again back on the training schedule
I also established a schedule where each
of our four platoons could rotate every
72 hours to a ski lodge and the Alps for
rest and relaxation the purpose of using
this retreat was to let the men get away
from the routine of a military schedule
so first of all when I got to SEAL team
1 and actually was it wasn't when I when
I first got there but there was a master
chief of SEAL team one that it showed up
in 1971 or 1972 to SEAL team one and
till team one you know you had 150 guys
roughly on the team at that time and
they had had 34 killed in action in
Vietnam at SEAL team 1 and wounded was I
don't know how many wounded but it was a
lot but this this guy who's a master
chief when I met him and he was telling
me that when he you know at the SEAL
team you you know you PT in the morning
just like a sports team you get you get
to work and you work out and you
that he's a new guy right and he's made
me PT and then they go in the shower you
know to wash off and it's the same thing
he's like looking at every single guy's
scarred up wounded you know slashes on
their chest bullet holes in him and he
kind of was saying to himself damn you
know this is this has been trial by fire
for these guys but beyond that what he's
talking about here clearly is if you and
I'll tell you this especially with you
know 18 year old 19 year old 20 year old
males that have joined the military if
you don't find something for them to do
productive they're going to find
something to do that's not going to be
productive it'll be fun formed yeah
it'll be fun for them they're gonna have
a good time but it's not there's a
chance they could be doing something
better than what you're letting them do
now of course he talks about the fact
that he's given still give them time to
go out to the ski lodge and and break
away from it a little bit but you just
got to be careful on how you do that you
got to be careful on how you do that
it's it can backfire if you're not
careful and the first time I was ever
kind of detached from a seal platoon
Donna I was when I went to training the
training department at SEAL team one
will used to call training cell which
sounds legit and it was hell Jen sure so
at training cell the first trip I went
on with a platoon because I was always
in the platoon so the first trip I went
on with the platoon and I was outside of
the platoon and I was you you could say
I was an instructor even though we
weren't running around calling ourselves
instructor instructors we would call
ourselves actually the CAD Dre I don't
know why is like oh yeah CAD Dre so I'm
still yes I was never an official term
it is an offender yeah cadre the
training cadre so when we were at
training cell because the instructors
are kind of considered the buds
instructors together the basic training
and we didn't really want to be buds
instructors we were the contract yeah
yeah so and neither I didn't May this is
just this is just by Otis
when I take up cadre I call ourselves
cadre and makeup training cell I wish I
made up all those things but I just
flowed into them as a lucky young new
guy but actually this point wasn't a new
guy anymore
wait but it's true though right it's not
like you just gave yourself a title that
one no no we're the collar yeah oh
training cadre yeah oh hey I need to
talk to guys Nicandro here yeah that's
what that's what we called ourselves
it's like well you know like let's say
you open a jujitsu gym and then you know
you're teaching people and then you're
like okay yeah I'm the instructor I'm
and then you say you know what I like
professor that's better yeah I don't
know what is that it's not that I didn't
make that no no they called you know
four years and actually I think Roger
Hayden talks about it when when he was
on the podcast he was talking about when
he was cadre so right it's been around
forever
right that's what I just like professor
it's like it's true as long as a
professor but it's like it just sound
it's just better you know it sounds
better so I go ahead go with that one
just go with cadre yeah like none of you
know what I was talking about
oh so I was I was in the cadre for the
first time and we went on a trip we went
to a trip where they have good times to
be had where we were there was a place
where there's some good training but
there's also good times and you know I
picked this up from Carly Flanagan this
new bridge I had really heard Wilding
did you hear that if I go we're just
Wilding yeah with us I think it better
term than the term that we discussed
which was partying right well there's
good we have we were partying yeah I
like wildest enter could that entails
all kinds of other things little bit
more a little bit more walk yeah Wilding
out or what's little while and I never
really heard anything I never really
heard it before he's but when Harley
said me clearly you know what it is yeah
yeah and it's in his book - we talked
about Wilding so we went to this place
with a seal platoon where there was good
training and good Wilding to the end and
I remember the first time that these
guys you know we get there we work a
little bit and then they're gonna go out
in into the town and I remember thinking
myself they been in the field for a few
days and they were all fired up young
frogman and I was thinking myself how is
this even gonna work like there's no
there's no possibility of this going
well and it did you know everyone fine
but you just see all these guys they're
ready to you know they're ready to
explode now you're going to they've been
in the field they've dehydrated they've
been in the field for four days or five
all dehydrated and they completed their
operation they feel good about it now
you're going to let them out in town
yeah you got to be careful in those
scenarios I'm going to put something
yeah we would you know sometimes you
just say hey look at you whatever you
want tonight but we're P team tomorrow
at zero 700 so then everyone knows they
they get wild to a point but they can't
yeah they got to put some kind of a
governor some kind of a berry scenario
here's a cool piece where dick winners
you know he talks known I've talked
about this before but just just a piece
about his view of what America was doing
at the time back to the book the United
States went to war not to conquer
territory or to subject their fellow man
but merely to liberate a conquered
people from the chains of tyranny there
is a certain nobility in all that today
we are bombarded in the news media about
how everyone hates America and how this
country is deployed around the world
World War two wasn't like that
and I'm proud to be a part of it so
again I've said this a bunch of times
you know we went there and lost hundreds
of thousands of people in Europe and and
in the Pacific Theater and we took
nothing we only gave some thoughts on
leadership from dick winters leadership
leadership defining quality is honesty -
honesty add fairness and consistency I
was able to develop a sixth sense during
the war that allowed me to size up a
situation rapidly I can look at terrain
and be able to see opportunities instead
of challenges by leading from the front
I believe I shaved a high degree of
success so I thought that was a very
very interesting combination honesty
fairness and consistency mm you don't
hear those a lot about being a great
leader I mean I always talk about the
number one at your beautiful leaders is
humility and
I definitely believe that humility is
important but honesty that's clearly a
thought and a concept of leadership that
I think that misses a lot of people I
think and we've talked about plenty of
cases on the podcast here where we say
oh what if this is going on and I say
look you want to be honest with them you
know so I've definitely said that before
but I'm going to start saying it more
because I'm learning a little something
from dick winters today but you know
yeah I remember we had a case where
someone was saying hey I'm going to
leave this job let me take another job
and what should i do should I tell them
should I not and we kind of went around
and I'll take a look to tell matures
just say look hey this is what's going
on I'm going to be I've got a better
opportunity I'm going to take it because
and in the long run you're in the long
run that's going to be you're going to
be better off if you're honest with
people and so obviously to think about
this quality it's something I've thought
about but not as clearly as this as dick
winters saying that's the defining
quality that's obviously important
something that I will talk about more
now definitely believed it but we'll
talk about it more now if you've seen
the movie Band of Brothers or the series
Band of Brothers they do a good job of
showing the beginning when they form up
and there's a guy and there's a guy in
leadership position called captain so
bail and he's not a good leader and they
do a good job of portraying why he
wasn't a good leader in the series but
here's what Dick winners had to say
about it back to the book captain Sobel
commanded through fear and intimidation
that is not how a leader should conduct
himself
sibel was not just unfair he was
mean-spirited his attitude created a
special bond with an easy company that
allowed the men to identify with their
platoons more so with in with the
company which is more normal in most
unit military units second lieutenants
by their nature are clannish group so
you got a company commander and then
he's got three usually three platoons
underneath them and each one of those is
run by a second lieutenant so the second
lieutenants are the platoon commanders
second lieutenants by their nature are
clannish group some are more serious
than others
for the most part they wander around a
military post as General Eisenhower once
said in a rather aimless search for
excitement
easy companies platoon leaders of which
I was one day our best to take care of
our soldiers to soften so bells
dictatorial behavior
I lost all respect for our commander the
day he announced the officers an Easy
Company we will lead through fear not by
example that's just the opposite of any
leadership principle that I could ever
conceive is to lead through fear instead
of example kind of like one when you're
dead well I don't know about you're dead
but if you're dead says or if you say to
your kids do what I say not what I do
you know that you heard that for sure
for sure but it went if you want to put
the fear onto that to do what I say not
what I do or else or else yeah I'm gonna
get out the belt for the kids down south
they say yeah then when I got the swoosh
get up a switch does you know not all
the time but he said that he said switch
where was he from that's from Brooklyn
New York
they got no switches in Brooklyn New
York I'm here to tell you uncle I they
did go I they found this all wrong he
made me go get my switch he said go get
a switch I don't know what that means by
the way at this point
okay little kid yeah go get and I'm from
quiet I don't say switch you know
apparently other people say switch I
didn't know which mean I'm kind of more
mad so then he had to brief you on what
a switch was yeah this is anything I'm
gonna be doing kind of like digging your
own grave Ian's away you know very 7:00
there's absolutely yeah
very similar yeah back to the book it
made such an impression on me that I
recorded his words in my diary under
ordinary circumstances a junior company
officer attempts to reflect his company
commanders leadership style but easy
company's lieutenants found that they
simply could not emulate the image of
cibele and still live with themselves
sibel had no friends within the company
and few within the regiment at the end
of each day he went one way and we
tenets one another hoping not to run
into him at the officer's club he lacked
confidence in his own ability as an
implicit commander he was he was
completely honest but he couldn't read a
map to save his neck his knowledge of
tactics and fire maneuver was extremely
poor so horrible situation and you know
this is this is one of those things
where he's talking about how everyone
known wanted to hang around him right
and I've heard leaders say a good
beaters not going to be like they're not
going to be loved by everyone and that
there's some truth to that right of
course not not everyone's gonna love you
but there's also a difference when no
one likes you
yeah you're not doing a good job you're
not doing a good job at all and you know
I I hung out with all my guys all the
time you through the chain of command
everyone to hang out let's go let's go
look this hangout wasn't running away
from the idea to water if you escape
yeah that's that's not a good sign
yeah like one guy say I'm not here to
make friends yeah that's another classic
right what any big friends know but I
actually you know there's I heard I've
heard officers say that in the military
seal officers I project look you you and
now they'll say like it's not a
popularity contest which is not clearly
you're going to make decisions that can
be hard for people to swallow but to
have people running away from you
because they don't like you as a human
being that's not a good position to be
in
you're not doing a good job as a leader
you need to reassess what you what you
what you're doing and how you're doing
it and this is kind of reflective of
what dick winters attitude was back to
the book Easy Company didn't belong to
me
it belonged to the soldiers I was
privileged to be a small part of its
history officers and commanders in
particular are merely caretakers that
the paratroopers respected me is more
than enough reward so there's this
totally totally different attitude right
and there's something weird that happens
with the military
you'll hear a guy
it's a contradictory stay here's a
dichotomy
you'll hear a guy say my soldiers on my
Marines and there's two ways that that
can be taken one of them is very
positive my soldiers I am going to take
care of my soldiers hey don't come down
here and talk to my soldiers like that
or hey you know I need to make sure my
soldiers have the gear that they need I
need to make sure my Marines have and
that's a they mean that in the best
possible way there's another side to
that which is completely negative which
is these are my Marines meaning you own
them meaning I'll do what I want with
them right and so I've seen guys on both
sides of that edge and you can hear a
good you can hear a good leader say my
Marines you can hear a good leader say
my soldiers are here good leader say my
SEALs and think of it too positively and
you can have a crappy leader say my
soldiers my Marines my SEALs and you
just think dude no no and so for and
especially when you get dick winners who
was you know universally respected in
his in the military and definitely in
his battalion and in his company and
he's a guy that saying look it was
theirs that just tells you that's where
your leadership perspective should come
from yeah I always felt that better way
that instead of saying my one of the few
things as far as feelings go because I I
experience that a lot when people be
like my this and that you know and I see
what you're doing it's like you're just
the boss and the owner of all this kind
of thing and okay I think but with it
felt like and feels like with people
like my soldiers you know there is a lot
of room for like cuz cuz man these are
my brothers I you know my guys but let's
say they're talking about like something
else like a big one like the bartenders
I used to work with every once in a
while you'd have one and say well I got
this and you know my bar and when they
talk to the customers you know they're
like hey what kind of bottle vodka DF
because well my best vodka is you know
this and that then they'd say my you
know kind of like I'm the master of this
whole domain here everything here is my
and that I can bestow upon you kind of
feeling and always kind of well they do
do it definitely in the military with
inanimate objects not being soldiers and
Marines and sailors they do it with
inanimate objects and if you learn that
bootcamp or the you know they say why
are you on my parade deck right yeah it
gives you this feeling of like paying
this guy's really into this parade deck
I mean you know where you do marching
they say get off my parade deck yeah and
it instills that kind of personal pride
about something so again even that one
can go both ways yeah I guess I guess it
really you really have to understand
what your intent is behind what you're
saying and you have to be careful I
always say I feel subconscious about
that and I'll give you an example my gym
yeah right my gym well when I talk about
victory MMA which you know we have
partners and it's not solely my gym well
but it's my gym where I can't train
right but sometimes someone will say
something and I'll feel like oh where do
you train you know and and I could say I
train to my gym you know what I mean I
feel like I'm real turn when I do that
if I got all victory I'm a man fitness
you know yeah oh gee mr. Jeff Glover
yeah that's where I train and only do
you own that place yeah I'm one of the
owners you know wha but yeah you feelin
like that my all you get to say interval
what I'm careful be careful with that I
always thought if you said our you know
especially even in a bartender situation
what we have it's kind of like us as an
establishment right now kind of thing
I'm part of that when you say our you're
part of it
you know so it kind of still puts that
forward like I'm kind of giving this to
you or offering whatever I'm taking some
ownership but it's like I'm not dumped
off of this thing it kind of feels that
way that's what I always thought even if
you like in your situation if you're
like you know someone's like hey talk
already trained say well at our gym you
know yeah and it's kind of ambiguous as
well which kindness seems more humble
it'll work it's like oh yeah you could
be just a member but at least you're
part of that community you know kind of
thing so yeah use our got it careful
that's what was like all
yeah absolutely careful with my marine
my soldiers and again sometimes that's
the most positive thing you could
possibly say mmm-hmm these are my seals
hey don't come down here and figure to
put my seals out the fields of bad
situations not happening you know what I
mean you're protective they're your
brothers you know you have ownership of
them but it's nice in a positive way as
opposed to look I'll deploy my seals
wherever I see fit to go put a put a red
flag on that dudes face Yeah right back
to the book I think of Easy Company
every day we sustained a hundred and
fifty percent casualties between the
night that we jumped into Normandy and
VE Day a hundred and fifty percent
casualties Rosie that are wondering how
you do that how you do that is you have
people getting wounded multiple times
and coming back to the front and when
your replacements show up they get
wounded too so you you know you've got
whatever 150 people in your in your
company and over the course of time
people get wounded and leave and new
people come in to take their place and
they get wounded as well and that's how
you get up over a hundred percent of
your people being wounded the result of
sharing all the stress throughout
training and combat has created a bond
between the men of Easy Company that
will last forever in a sense I don't
think I ever left Company E I may never
again see the type of men in this outfit
but to me Easy Company will always be my
company in the sense that I will always
remain a part of it to this day they
remain my second family I still look at
these men with great respect respect I
can't describe in words so there he
makes it same thing like he feels
uncomfortable saying mine he has to put
a quantifier on it and then explain hey
not in that sense but I'll always be a
part of it that's why it's
more about leadership back to the book
leadership is difficult to define they
talk about leadership at West Point
everyday leadership starts with honesty
dedication and having a man who is
dependable and fair if you never deviate
from the standards that you established
men have faith in you and you'll be out
front to set the example sergeant
Talbert once told me sir I'd follow you
into hell
I take a great deal of pride in his
remark so again we're getting this
leadership starts with honesty
dedication dependable and fair so
important so important being fair and
you need to see that a lot when it comes
to doling out punishment when people
make mistakes
are you fair you know does that person
really deserve to lose their pay for 90
days or go on bread and water or
whatever kind of punishment are going to
bestow on someone yes sir
and people know if things are fair or
not people know what's reasonable hey do
you think that you know when people say
I'm gonna make an example out of
somebody for sometimes it's for
different reasons maybe like oh I've
been letting people slack so I gotta I
gotta make an example out of somebody to
kind of reestablish the discipline type
of thing or maybe you know as a boss or
whatever you really don't like this
specific violation like you just read
just one of your things you know so you
can make an example for that reason do
you think that that's fair it can be but
it's also a touchy subject you tell me I
personally think let's say I've been
given some slack and people been showing
up a little bit late showing up a little
bit late and I'm kind of like hey man
you know we need to be a little more on
time and then find me on a Thursday guy
shows up late for the meeting and I say
hey you're suspended you're grounded
you're you know you have to work this
weekend I promise impart super-hard that
doesn't make sense right it doesn't make
sense and people say oh you know I'm not
good not being consistent because people
then they make
however if I was to say hey guys check
it out bill just walking in right now
and I've been letting it slide and I'll
tell you what this is where it's getting
us we've been later later we start
slacking here we're gonna start slacking
in other places we can't afford to slack
right now our missions too important
from now on if we're late if you're late
showing up to this meeting or you late
to an evolution that we're about to do
I'm gonna drop the hammer hmm
so don't be late is that fair yeah fair
warning explanation as to why that's
fair in my opinion just going off the
handle and smashing someone because you
want to make an example them that
doesn't make sense to me yeah I don't
like it I don't do it yes that makes
sense can it be useful yes if someone if
there's a clearly delineated expectation
that's been set and it gets violated for
whatever reason and you are going to
crush and destroy to set an example and
actually we're get to a point where he
talks about that in here there is an
example set and that has to send a
message to everyone yeah that ya can do
that I've done that with my family yeah
hey here's a line if you cross it you
will remember you're a very long time
that you made a bad decision yes and my
other kids when I've done that to some
one of my kids that has made a bad
decision they all remember all of them
yeah they don't want to make that
mistake yeah it seems like you a little
off the line no not at all like it how
you said if you give them kind of ample
warning where you kind of given the
tools to make their own decision
anything even if you are changing a
policy or whatever you know harsher
punishments all this stuff as long as
yeah you warned them like how you're
saying that seems like fair and the huge
one which I always kind of thought was
if it applies to everyone you know like
if if this violation this punishment for
this violation applies to everyone sure
it just happens to be this guy because
he just happened he's be the one he
happens to be the one that committed the
violation or whatever but this rule this
policy applies to everybody yeah and
also when you when you explain these
things you don't blame them if you
notice even when I just said you know
hey guys I bring back here you don't say
look you guys missed like I said look I
didn't make it clear why this is
yeah and therefore you guys have been so
you know I've been letting you slack you
guys have been showing up late that's a
problem we can't have that problem
anymore so you just don't start pointing
fingers everyone yeah and then hammering
those harsh punishments no not a good
idea you can reduce it back to the book
I believe that some men and women are
born with the inherent qualities that
make them good leaders writing to his
son John who is a cadet at West Point in
1943 General Eisenhower once said the
one quality that can be developed by
studious reflection and practice is the
leadership of men I agree with Ike
leaders are not born leaders are made
and they are made by solid effort and
hard work so it's a little contradictory
in there because he says look some
people are born with qualities that make
them a good leader but you can learn to
be a good leader I totally agree with
that I've always said that some people
have the qualities that make them a good
leader naturally are they a lot of some
of them right similar be really
articulate some will be very charismatic
very dynamic loud I have a lot of
presence those are all characteristics
that will differentiate in different
people and if you have a lot of those
you're going to have a naturally easier
time being a good leader now
occasionally you get people that have
some of those qualities but they're
idiots and those are the worst because
they can get people to follow them even
though they don't know where they're
going yeah those are bad situations but
the agender esting hard work studying
right studying leadership I you know
today I already learned something need
to increase my focus on honesty as a
leadership quality but yeah I'm always
studying always learning and we all need
to be that's how we're going to become a
better leader and a lot of the studying
that I did when I was growing up in the
teams was just what I was watching and
thinking about why these leaders were
doing what they're doing what is making
them do this good leader why is why why
does that why do we respond to that well
bad leader why don't you respond well to
what he's doing I wasn't sitting there
consciously thinking about it actually
no in some days I was actually
consciously thinking about it you know
consciously thinking wait why is no one
want to follow the
how is he acting that we all want to
walk away from him why is that happening
and then when we get a good leader I say
this why is this guy such a good leader
mm-hmm so yeah I guess I did consciously
do that and study not from books but
from life to try and learn and that's
how you can become better here's a
little note too
and and you want to talk about holding
the line if you aren't in good physical
shape forget it you are not going to be
a good leader well certainly in a
military environment that is true there
are there some civilian leaders that
aren't in the best shape yeah there are
would those leaders be doing a better
job if they were in better physical
condition yes they would it's like that
that seeing that starting strength coach
Roberto says I post I've never talked
about it but I posted he's talking about
how physical strength is good and people
that say that physical strength aren't
good he says you know you forget the
exact quote but he's basically saying I
know
physical strength is good and if you
take someone that says the physical
strength isn't good
oh and is it important and then you add
a hundred and twenty pounds to their
squat and then ask him how they're doing
now they're going to be doing better
they're going to be doing better the
more you can deadlift the better you're
going to feel you don't feel worse when
you can deadlift more you don't feel
worse when you can squat more you feel
better yeah what why is that there's a
million reasons why confidence
overcoming the challenge you're actually
physically stronger your mental clarity
goes up so yeah of course be in good
shape
be in good shape if you're worried about
your health you're not going to be able
to focus on being a good leader and in
the military or in any job where that
demands physical exertion you have to be
in good shape
otherwise people are looking at you
you're falling apart you can't be
falling apart on patrol you can't be
falling apart during a during a combat
swimming operation where you know you
need to swim you need this win far
you're going to swim for four straight
hours on the combat swimmer operation if
you're weak and you can't
do that you think your men are going to
respect you mmm they're not all going to
answer that question for you yeah that
kind of like the hockey coach he doesn't
even know how to ice skate you know
there are coaches that have never
participated in the sport that they
coach and they're good they're I mean
you can look at Greg Jackson is a great
mixed martial arts coach he's never been
a mixed martial arts fighter yeah but he
knows how to fight them you know yeah
certainly does yes but he hasn't
actually fought so how can he be a good
coach what about Duke Rufus he's never
fought MMA has he oh and I mean he's not
moving yeah we know he's a champion
kickboxer but how can he be such a great
coach at MMA yeah because he can connect
the dots and stuff like that and of
course there's you know there's
exceptions every but generally speaking
and plus you talking about a little bit
more of a broadening like a leader like
who you gonna like follow yeah yeah I'm
talking about coaches I mean you coaches
are not participating anymore that's why
they're coaching
yeah so I guess those are really stupid
examples yeah well first let's just go
because because you know Kosta motto
with Mike Tyson obviously wasn't getting
in the ring with Mike Tyson right yeah
but he's a great coach or fantastic
coach one of the most you know one of
the most respected coaches of all time
yeah and the results are a little bit
more like recognizable like the less
ambiguous like a leaders result close
yeah and we're look we're looking at
leaders in the field like leaders in the
job that are leading a group to
accomplish a mission right that's
different than a coach a bitch is
outside the group yeah yeah and so we're
talking about someone that's in the
group yeah you got to be you got to be
able to maintain you got to be able to
stay with your team physically and you
know it's not like you need to be the
best I was never the fastest guy was
never the strongest guy but I wasn't
going to be falling behind right on a
Patrol is I wasn't in good shape that
wasn't going to happen yeah and the only
way that doesn't happen is you need to
stay in shape how do you say and say got
a discipline built yeah these questions
answer themselves at some point maybe
something like this podcast will just
come on here and sit here into silence
yeah good idea
speaking of now this is this is a good
that you were talking about this here is
a heavy punishment handed out
talking about Colonel Bob sinc who was
the leader of the 506 parachute infantry
regiment area back to the colonel bob
sink certainly was one of the best he
set high standards and never compromised
on those standards after the
paratroopers of the 506 a pair troop
paratroop parachute infantry regiment
earned their jump wings sink granted a
10 day furlough but cautioned the men to
conduct themselves appropriately several
paratroopers reported late for duty
after their furloughs expired sink
called another regimental formation and
publicly humiliated one paratrooper from
each of his nine companies they called
out the name of the last soldier to
report to duty and that paratrooper was
marched in front of the formation under
escort an officer stripped him of his
unit patch forced him to unbless boots
and then escorted him from the field
what sink was saying was paratroopers
may be elite but they had to follow the
Army's rules and regulations I liked
that
for some reason sink like me respected
me he was always the man instrumental in
getting me my next job so there's a
heavy punishment now that's that's a
clear message being sent right clear
message being sent and I bet Colonel
sink at that time laid mean he's got
three nine companies so he's got
hundreds and hundreds of guys the
hundreds and hundreds of guys and he's
going to make an example out of nine of
them and he's going to be a real clear
example and that's gonna leave an
impression on a thousand guys you know
in close to a thousand guys mm-hmm
that might be worth it and he probably
judged that it was worth yeah so
interesting perspective yeah I guess the
question is is that fair only the way I
would say to the guys that got
booted from the regiment I'd say their
thoughts were that it was unfair I would
say for the guys that remained in the
regiment that realized that they had to
maintain the standard that realized
there was going to be no slack and that
worked hard to make sure they maintain
that and therefore were more prepared
for combat
that's it was real fair right so bigger
picture kind of thing it was kind of the
martyr you know yeah that gives a real
big picture thing and who knows what
kind of behind the scenes we would have
to get some details if we were really to
cast judgment on that like you know
maybe some of those guys were kind of
slackers anyways yeah and the company
commander was like hey dude yeah we
don't want this guy you know let's get
rid of this guy or whatever you know
yeah and he only took certain members of
the people that missed their furlough he
seems that's not fair he only took
certain members or certain people that
that missed their furlough didn't take
all of them yeah just the last one to
report you know we don't take that
around here yeah it's an interesting
dynamic you know it's an interesting
dynamic but it's definitely showing I I
don't know that unnecessarily we've done
that I can admire some my my assessment
I probably wouldn't know yeah not not
one guy from each company maybe like the
two guys that grossly violated it I
don't think I would need to do nine yeah
I'll guess what Colonel sink did it'll
mess with girl sink and that's a good
thing little little kind of image for
you to have don't mess with Colonel sink
don't mess around in the battalion in
the regiment
we don't play hmm another leader that he
talks about here is McAuliffe back to
the book what we liked about McAuliffe
was that he allowed us to do our jobs
you didn't have a lot of interference
from McAuliffe but with Taylor in
command that's another person he told
you what you needed to do here he had to
run everything you can't do a good job
if you don't have the chance to use your
imagination and creativity in my mind
kayla was more interested in in
impressing his superiors than watching
out for his men Taylor was such a
contrast
with British general Montgomery so he
talks a little bit Oh
okay so first of all clearly
decentralized command give people the
clear field specifics on how to do every
little thing let them get creative with
them come up with a solution
perfect boom we hear that over and over
again why do we hear it over and over
again because it's right because it's
right that's why we hear it over and
over again now he talks about the famous
British general Montgomery Monty who
always gets portrayed a little bit stiff
and a little bit British right and he
says in here that the writers don't
didn't know him didn't see him on the
battlefield didn't see what he was like
and here's what he says here's a dick
winter said about Montgomery back to the
book Montgomery was the real deal I saw
him on a number of occasions and he
always impressed me as a commander who
lived the lifestyle that was beyond
reproach for his staff to follow he set
the example he addressed every division
that was scheduled to participate in the
invasion he called us together and had
every soldier take off his helmet so he
could see the troops better yeah props
to Monty right going around and talking
to every every single division and then
said hey boys take off your helmets I
want to see your faces before you all mm
get props there's this book a lot of
this books about self discipline even
this part right here back to the book
self discipline keeps you doing your job
without it you lose your pride and
forget the importance of self-respect
and the eyes of your fellow men pride
keeps you going on this is what I feared
I would lose the loss of the will to
measure up to my men so once you say you
know what I don't care what my guys
think anymore you've lost it right
mm-hmm
if I say look I don't care what the guys
think of me think of what a driving
force it is to have your team looking at
you and saying I'm gonna make sure these
guys respect me and I'm proud of what
I'm doing compared to I don't care what
anyone thinks to me anymore you can see
when you can see what
when this happens to people not just in
the military or business organizations
but in life yeah in life at a certain
point you see a bomb in the street at a
certain point that bum said you know
what I don't care what anyone thinks me
anymore yeah I don't care what my family
thinks me I don't care what the society
thinks of me yeah of course I'm not
talking about every single bump but a
lot of them yeah hey I don't care
generally is the thing and as soon as
you see that you can imagine that you
that that's just like a life thing right
you know if you go through life and you
don't care what anyone else thinks which
is a contradiction for me right because
I'll say all time like I don't care what
people think yeah but that's to just to
a degree like you and it's obvious and
just put a little bit of thought and you
don't care about what people say well as
it appears you don't care what people
think on a superficial level you know on
a profound level you do that's why
you're you know that's why part of your
morality is like you know fairness doing
the right thing all this discipline
stuff it's for you but in regards to
social cues and all these things like
that that's beneficial to your success
to function in the society yeah and I've
said this before like about the SEAL
Teams and me being in the SEAL Teams
and I had this completely had this
attitude I don't care like for instance
I don't care what happens like I don't
care if I get fired I'm gonna do the
right thing I don't care I don't care
what they think of me and it's the same
thing at the same time there's nothing
that was more important to me than my
reputation the SEAL Teams hmm I don't
want you know if if something was going
to give you a bad rep like when we just
talked about if you fall out of a patrol
as a leader or as anyone like if you
fall out of a shawl you're going to no
one's ever going to forget it in the
SEAL Teams if you're too weak to do
something you're gonna be remembered by
that forever and that I didn't want that
ever to be like Oh Jocko did this Jocko
couldn't finish patrol Jocko was a bad
leader Jocko I didn't want that to be
the reality yeah and so therefore you
work hard you stay in shape you do your
best all the time
yeah and that drives you yeah but at the
same time
I wasn't saying oh I I'm concerned what
my boss thinks of me so I'm going to act
a certain way and I'll try to do the
right thing
for the teams right way Jim say no like
these guys these are all tubes those are
fundamental things yeah no weird is a
weird balance though to say look I don't
care if I get promoted but I care more
than anything about my job you know to
me and that definitely was my attitude
that definitely was my attitude my whole
time I was in the military look I'm I'm
gonna do the best job I can I'm not
doing it to get promoted I'm not doing
it for that reason
yeah but I am part of it absolutely
doing it to have the respect of my peers
and my bros on the teams right you rep
being in a reputation you get off on
your reputations everything in the SEAL
Teams because it's a small group of
people you know you have an accidental
discharge with your weapon everybody
knows about it they're gonna know about
it forever if you if you remain on the
teams for whatever reason after you have
an accidental discharge everyone's going
to know it from there on out and it's
not fun that's why we got Matson jacked
up nicknames in the SEAL team because
you're gonna get nicknamed after your
lowest point in your life the biggest
mistake is what you're going to get next
named or your biggest yeah like there
was a guy and I his nickname was Bush
and he's a great dude mm-hmm
the nickname was Bush it had nothing to
do his last name but anyways long story
short would use a new guy and I knew him
this is 15 years later I found this out
he's so he'd been in the SEAL Teams for
15 years I known him as Bush the whole
time and he was parachuting brand new
guy showed up the team they're like hey
you're going jumping today okay gets in
the aircraft jumps and he he lands
through no fault you can't even steer
these Brown parachutes you can't barely
steer him he lands in a bush with like
four right and I guess it looks pretty
funny
and from there on yeah what's his name
boy yeah so you're going to get a name
like that but that's a that's a really
easy example because everybody knows hey
that's just funny there's more of a
funny thing if he's something funny
happens to you might get that nickname
too like if you get pepper sprayed by
the cops you might have the nickname
pepper
I like the direct it is
yeah there's no sense to play it around
what else you gonna call some of the
hits pepper-sprayed by the cops or their
new guy you're gonna call pepper call my
tie or something wet I yeah you know cuz
you guys get all water you do not have
you're not in charge of makin remember
your guys that you thought to name was
his name was Al yeah but it was ow
yeah al 50 Cal not even his name my name
is a big out 50 Cal yeah what are you it
morphed yes awesome so that's why you
have this weird dichotomy that's pulling
at you is just to you're looking at your
your friends your peers in this in a
leadership position
it's your men you're looking at your men
saying hey I don't want to let these
guys down I don't want them to view me
as weak yeah bad word but I guess it's
the word I'm looking for
you know not that I not that I want to
maintain the image of strength because
part of maintaining the image of
strength is by showing weakness right in
like I said it's all time hey I don't
know how to do this hey can you give me
a suggestion I'm not talking about that
type of thing I'm talking about
we physical witness a physical and
mental toughness or physical mental
weakness right that's a lot different
than hey I don't understand how to do
something or it's a lot different than
humility you can you can want to show
you can want to maintain strength but
still have humility for sure yeah I know
all kinds I mean I know tons of guys
that are completely humble but they're
the toughest bastard you'd ever wanna
know mentally and physically so I'm not
talking about I need to be strong
stronger than everyone no I'm not
talking about that at all I'm talking
about you physical and mental toughness
you have to have and if you don't have
them as a leader could be problematic
yeah watch out for it back to the book
the big thing I derived from combat was
the necessity of maintaining discipline
disciplining our troops was discipline
in our troops and getting the job done
in combat
so clearly disciplines a big part of
what we're talking about here gee I
wonder why now this is
talking another little aspect that you
know I don't talk about this a lot I
think it's inherent and a lot of things
that I say but it's not something that I
don't use this word a lot and again I
think I need to use it more back to the
book character revolves around doing the
right thing all the time
character implies daily choices of right
over wrong the cadet prayer at West
Point says cadets strive to choose the
harder right instead of the easier wrong
and never to be content with a
half-truth when the whole can be one
that gets to the heart of character I
would add that it is easier to do the
right thing when everyone is looking it
is more difficult to do what you should
do when you are alone I like to think of
character as every other virtue at the
breaking point
so character doing the right thing doing
the right thing in all times doing the
right thing when you're alone yeah back
to the book war doesn't alter character
war merely brings out the best that an
individual has to offer unfortunately it
also brings forth the worst in some men
if anything war exposes the best and
worst of those who are called the fight
I know of no man who lacked character
and peace and then discovered character
in combat so I've said this same type of
thing before especially any war
you know we'd see on deployment is as
pressure starts to build on people you
start seeing people go into directions
then that's what we take this is their
character would start to reveal itself
they either get very big rise to the
occasion or they would not and they go
in the other direction and become the
worse their character would become worse
or their character
better that's what I've seen and the
same thing you know we talk about people
that have maybe have a hard time dealing
with war a lot of times there's some
pre-existing issues that the war in
flames right and then if you take
someone that has that doesn't have
pre-existing issues or maybe has a
positive spin on things that becomes
more positive so it's very and then
there's a bunch of people in the middle
but some of the guys that I knew that
really had a hard time they had issues
going in you know they had problems some
issues going in to the situation going
into war and those problems get
exacerbated by the pressure in the
stress of combat so we need to watch out
for that one
and I think I think war is more of an
amplifier than a creator I think it
amplifies good character I think it
amplifies bad character I think it
amplifies issues and in either direction
so it's a it's a it's a powerful element
to add into people's lives this this big
intense piece now one of the things that
this led this book captures is these
letters he kind of had a pen pal a
female pen pal when he was a war her
name is Deanna almond and one of the
things that he so he's going to capture
these letters and some of the letters
parts of some of the letters are
published in here here's one of them
back to the book first and most
important I've got my own conscience to
answer to next my parents and then I am
an officer in the US Army I am damn
proud of it and with the rank and
position I hold I wouldn't think of
doing anything to bring discredit to my
outfit my paratrooper boots wings
the airborne patch or the US Army good
morale within an outfit is usually
reflected by good conduct away from it
that sounds like an idealistic high
school kid
I know but that's it that's how I feel
so he took that stuff very very
seriously and I remember I remember
broken the dirt free war I was in my
third Platoon and the new guys who are
all my bros now I mean these are just
mugs but they were new guys and we were
the senior older guys right because
we've been in the teams for like a
couple years and something happened and
we gave like a like a like hey guys
don't don't ever make the platoon look
bad like no matter what you don't make
the platoon look fat that's not allowed
mmm double tuned is comes first above
everything and this one I just remember
saying but then one guy made the platoon
look that then he had to pay for it but
that's the attitude the attitude is like
look you don't make the platoon look bad
you don't make the team's look bad we
didn't really we weren't too concerned
with the Navy back then we didn't really
even see like when I was that young and
the SEAL Teams we weren't even thinking
about the big Navy we barely even
recognized it we were in the teams it's
more it's because like as as the teams
became bigger and more prevalent
we connected more with the big Navy when
all the new guys in the studio when I
was in the SEAL Teams as a young guy in
the 90s we were pretty much on our own
so I wasn't a bit basically I wasn't
like sitting there thinking and you
protect the reputation of Navy I don't
care I went now as I got older I did but
back in the day it was like hey the
platoon and and I was a team on a time
and team one you know make team one look
that what are you doing
don't make this platoon look bad you
just did that yeah you now you have to
pay for that mmm punishment will be
delivered at this time and it was the
unfortunate situation you know these
things just happen to time to time so
are we not going into what the
punishment was that day the punishment I
the punishment was I'll tell you what
the punishment was Jocko punishment the
punishment was I am going to strike you
two times in the face with an open hands
that's your punishment or we're going to
fight which one do you want that was the
punishment yeah he and this guy was like
I'll take two - yeah and I like Roger
that and it was a little bit more
tension than that you know yeah fully
that's really then like bowed up a
little bit yeah and I was like oh if you
want to get it on we'll get it on yeah
and and you know it's funny because
these guys this group of guys who is
they were they were all guys just trying
to get after it and be good team guys
but we were just crazy you know at this
point and the teams was literally
everything in my life so when I was like
mad about disrespecting or making the
platoon look bad it need like hurt me
you know I was that crazy that I just
didn't want the platoon look bad
yeah you know and you did something that
made him look bad yeah it really bad me
it really truly bothered me you made a
man that made team one look I mean I had
been there you know since I was a kid
you know it was everything to me
mmm and so when you didn't when you made
us look bad I wasn't happy and not just
I wasn't happy because I was a jerk or I
wasn't because I was being a jerk at the
time but talking to you guys you know
years later doctors guys they're like
yeah that guy particulars like I hate it
going to work I hated you guys sounds
like yeah yeah I'm sorry and then
they'll be like but I'm glad it was like
that because everybody has that feeling
it was an old school like with the old
breed know hey that's the way it is this
is we hold the line we don't make the
platoon look bad we make them look good
we work hard that's what we do it's like
a little game yeah that's all it was
yeah that's crazy those two choices cuz
they're like they're just different cuz
some people would rather go do the fight
because you know at least they they
can't go down swinging kind of attitude
but the potential for damage is way more
same but and then I agree with you and
you can see where you can make a case
for both of those selections but there's
also something cool it's like I'll take
two hits to the face
the open hand cool
I'm a man I screwed up I think that's
the reason I respected it was because it
wasn't it was like yeah I did screw up
right so then I'll take it I deserve
punishment leave it to me
yeah and that was that yeah well then we
move on no factor yeah technically the
two to the face are is way easier
because it's way quicker you you know
you know what to expect I mean unless
you're scared of like Oh hitting your
head and dying or some come off they
were opened and though they were open
here yeah see so you're not going to
knock anybody out with open hand yeah
well I'll usually or not you know maybe
I could I'm skinny but um yeah so a lot
of that is like that how you say you
were kind of building some tension with
it it's like that's a big part of the
punishment as well that's psychological
like torture story and and this also
reveals my own personal immaturity right
these are this is it like seriously this
is when I'm thinking about it this is
just an immature you know I was probably
22 years old maybe 23 years old but you
know young and immature and not getting
the best guidance not understanding
things not understanding that I wasn't
helping build a cohesive unit not
understanding that this guy's probably
thinking oh I don't want to help him you
know I mean it wasn't he smart I'm not
I'm not trying to say that this stuff
was smart I'm telling you the reality of
the way it was and the way it was in my
head was hey this is my life yeah this
your platoon I know it sounds crazy this
seal platoon that we're in is my whole
life and I actually don't care about
anything else
mind you this is in the 90s there's no
war going on I'm just a young crazy kid
and the only thing I know and the only
thing I care about is the SEAL Teams and
you know you make the platoon look bad
this platoon is my life and you just
made us look bad and I can't stand that
and I don't want it to be that way
so young immature me what do I do
hey this is there's got to be punishment
mmm you know and that's kind of the
attitude we had and there are some
benefits to it because the you know it's
our wave I would love to go back and be
a better mentor and be like hey man this
is the mistake you made you know we need
to make you know I would love to
but you can't you're dumb I was a young
dumb kid that was raised that way by the
way as well that's how we were raised
yeah and there are some benefits to it
and like I said even those guys that did
platoons with me when I was
quote-unquote an old guy even though we
were nothing we'd never been to combat
we were meaningless but we had a couple
more years in the SEAL team so therefore
you're an old guy and the new guys are
anyone with with no deployments which is
actually pathetic in its own right
because the term in the SEAL Teams being
oh you're a new guy that was some guys
that were in Vietnam that you hadn't
been in combat yes and you're a new boy
you're a cherry boy hmm so guess what I
was a cherry boy for 17 years because I
never shot my weapon at the enemy I
didn't been in combat until I went to my
first deployment to Iraq so there's
actually from that perspective it's
embarrassing because here I was big I'm
an old guy was an old guy I never been a
combat before what am I talking about
yeah but you you take what you had at
the time where was this organization the
SEAL Teams my platoon and again you
can't I can't describe really how
important the seal platoon was to me it
was my won't be pretty this great it was
my whole life
Ingle what I do when I woke up in the
morning went in went into work worked
out with my seal platoon mates what do
we do
then we worked all day what do we do for
lunch we ate together what do we do at
night we went got dinner what do we do
after that we went to had drinks what do
we do after that we hung out all night
what do we do after that we went to
sleep woke up and did the same thing at
day after day that was my family mmm and
you just have this this passion for your
family and you it just meant is the most
important thing in the world to me for
my adult life but when you take that you
put that on a you know young kid yeah
and you know everyone's like oh yeah
Jacko's he he's a big reader I wasn't
reading anything back I was reading up
the platoon handbook right I wasn't
reading I wasn't reading her Shakespeare
sure yeah I want was I doing in high
school I wasn't paying attention during
high school I was wanting to be a
commando I was running through the woods
pretending I had a machine gun so you
take that kid and you put him in a
situation where
the thing that he cares about the most
has been scorns violated or scorned he's
going to try and handle it yeah the best
of his abilities start slapping people
I'm not proud of it but occasionally
some people that slapped around yeah
that's how though you know you know when
you're basic
young basic guy you can handle things in
a young basic kind of way yeah yeah
whatever it's it's caveman
yes caveman scenario there you go and
any other thing is and you know those
guys that were in those early platoons
when I was a collective set of
quote-unquote leaders later they're like
yeah that was awesome
so glad I got raised that way they're
proud of it yeah you know but at the
same time you uh you you when I look
back on it I know I was not a good
leader right by any stretch yeah it's
kind of like when I look at my old
videos you know at the time I like yeah
they were dope you know but you're like
me you just know better ways now you
know you're just better now yeah you
know I'm psyched 2021 yeah and then the
other thing you got to be careful of is
setting the bar like let's say I was in
the silicon right now and now I'm going
to set the bar so high that I lose track
of the lose vision of the fact that like
hey the guy that I'm trying to convince
right now is a 23 year old thing and the
most important thing in his world is
this is funny like I was talking to
someone the other day I couldn't
remember what super to know what the
phonetic letter of a certain seal
platoon I was in a certain time I'll
look after he wants to that was yeah and
to me at the time when we were in those
symptoms that letter of that phonetic
alphabet we were in alpha platoon that
was it and now I look back and it's like
oh yeah what platoon was that because as
I matured and as I saw the rest of the
world I realized that even though the
seal platoon is very important and
certainly it's the most important thing
when you're in it when you're in a task
unit or you're overseas and there's
multiple people running around and
there's huge missions going you you hope
your mind gets opened up yeah and you
see more and this little thing that you
used to be so engulfed in your head
becomes becomes less that's all there is
to it yeah now I'm telling you guys this
you
there's no better job like it's the best
thing in the world I'm sure you know I
never served in a in a Marine Corps
infantry platoon or in a in a Army US
Army improving but I saw them I saw what
they were like and they have that same
you know bond that that you get from
being in those tough units so there's
something very cool about that about
being a grunt and which is what you are
in the SEAL Teams you might think all
the Special Operations or whatever
you're a grunt you carry a machine gun
yeah and you do hard things
that's what being a grunt is you're
doing hard things you're carrying a
bunch of weight around those days love
those days yeah all right so I just want
to be back in the seal is so bad yeah
kind of so fun so so awesome yeah so
awesome so meaningful I would have
fought you yeah yeah yeah it wouldn't
know what happened you know what would
have happened I don't know I don't know
Valley that was one of the good things
about knowing a little tiny bit of
jujitsu which I actually knew a little
bit yeah that was enough yeah you gotta
fight guys would cut you know with comes
injures come what if you offer to fight
them and they'd kick your ass you're
like dang my that backfired and here's
the thing they didn't know any better
all they thought was they didn't I don't
think I ever said like I know jujitsu
you don't but it was just I was so
confident like oh I actually know this
and I know that I can choke this dude
then they just said you know what this
guy's probably gonna kick my ass
yeah and the weird thing is there's
probably guys a long way that could have
kicked me you know some kid that
wrestled in high school it all double
leg boom yeah and now I'm slammed on the
ground I getting punched in the head I
don't like it you know it's it's lesson
not learned yeah lesson not learned I'm
lucky that never happened so check all
right here we're talking about so I just
was talking about this is interesting so
I was just talking about mental strength
and physical strength or here we go back
to the book moral courage is a far rarer
commodity than physical
courage in that I agree with Hatton I
have known many officers who were
physically brave but who did not have
the intestinal fortitude to organize the
chaos around them those officers who
were the most vocal about what they were
going to do to the enemy often were the
first to fall apart when the chips were
down
fear is not only debilitating but its
existence also destroys the cohesion of
a command it is the responsibility of a
commander to identify the limits of
courage break the paralysis of fear and
motivate his soldiers to continue with
the mission courage conquers fear I like
just that that part and I don't think I
did this in helmet for my pillow there
was a part in helmet for my total that I
pulled out when I was talking to one of
my seal buddies and I was because he
listened to reason yeah yeah and I was
telling someone part that I didn't put
in the podcast I sent him a picture of
it from the book this little paragraph
but it's basically one of the
instructors one of the drill instructors
was all yelling about we're gonna kill
and blah blah blah and then he says yeah
the next time I saw him we were in you
know on island in the fight and he was
getting taken away but after breaking
down okay so this is what he's saying
here a lot of guys that are the loudest
about what they're gonna do to the enemy
yeah yeah okay you're talking a big game
you know but what's really gonna happen
either where else that happens UFC yeah
right mmm-ma it happens yeah I'm gonna
come across that guy and the other guys
sitting there going okay bring it yeah
or he's in the locker room like
explaining to all his teammates yeah
I'll just I'm gonna do this and I'm
gonna do that and it's almost like we're
trying to you're trying to convince them
could help so yeah yeah so that's what
that's what's going on here say yeah
right something trying to convince
themselves they're not confident in
themselves yeah back to the book I
suspect every soldier at one time or
another experiences a degree of fear
courage is not the absence of fear but
rather the willingness to rise above
fear and do the things you know need to
be accomplished all soldiers hope that
they will measure up the first time they
get into a fight I certainly was notes
but I believe I had prepared myself very
well that once I came under fire I knew
instinctively what needed to be done I
think I was more apprehensive
particularly before d-day than I was
afraid maybe apprehension is the first
stage of fear I'm not really sure you
have to remember that Easy Company was
melee unit as were all paratroopers we
had trained for nearly two years before
we jumped into Normandy
I think I saw far more excitement in the
eyes of my men then I did fear after
Bray court we felt as if we were
seasoned veterans even though we knew
worse days were ahead that apprehension
and definitely my first deployment to
Iraq when you had all these guys bro the
guys were so fired up to get it to do
real missions and get after it that I
think it was much more excitement than
it was fear especially in the beginning
and indicating you know there was a lot
of cash peace going on we're kind of
dominating right and you know even
showing up to a lot of the same thing
that's like sign me up what mission I'm
going yeah and the more you spend time
to that the more you realize what the
threat is and you start losing guys or
having guys getting wounded that's when
you start saying okay wait a second I'm
not sure I want to die today
and then guys got to overcome that on a
daily basis yeah speaking of fear Steve
Ambrose who's a military historian read
bunch of books including bandar brothers
Steve Steve Ambrose says that heavy
artillery bombardment will make even the
most seasoned veteran eventually break I
disagree a leader has to overcome fear
convinced himself that every enemy shell
or bullet is not targeting him the same
is true in a company or a battalion
leaders must ensure that strength and
cohesion is a stronger force than fear
this is especially true in men who have
been scarred by prolonged combat Ambrose
was correct when he titled the chat
her band of invantive brother's breaking
point as he describes the horrendous
artillery barrage that inflicted so many
casualties on Easy Company in the boys
ox company strength was below 50% and
many of the noncommissioned officers
were killed or wounded without direct
supervision by leaders Easy Company as
well as the remainder of the battalion
could have easily been div debilitated
by an increased sense of morality and
fear that is precisely why I made it a
point to visit the frontlines as often
as possible soldiers need to sense need
a sense that their leaders and
commanders are in the game with them
leadership by example is even more
important in these situations I noticed
that when men are at the edge of their
physical endurance you tend to develop
that 1000 yard stare that you always
read about tired soldiers will often
take off their helmet and run their
fingers through their hair talked about
that before and I talked about that
quite often now at times they literally
drop their helmets on the ground this
soldier is already losing his
self-respect the battle is half lost
that's a sign for the commander to take
immediate action I didn't wait for the
trooper to reach reach that stage I
proactively looked for these signs every
soldier wants to do the right thing you
always know the proper thing to do but
doing it is sometimes more difficult I
never wanted a man to lose his
self-respect that's what I was talking
about earlier this thing of cell this
idea of self-respect when you don't care
because you know you guys supposed to
keep your gear on all the time that's
like just the code right you can keep
your gear with you all the time to keep
your gear on all the time the minute you
take that off is where you start hanging
up care what these guys think anymore
something has happened that has made you
say you know what I don't care what
these guys think anymore and that's not
good yeah again this is such a
contradiction because you know we can
sit here and talk about like hey I don't
care what people think and I mean that I
mean that
shouldn't care what people think but at
the same time it should be extremely
important to you what people think and
what your comrades think and that's such
a weird dichotomy I don't think I've
fully wrapped my hands around how to
describe that yet and what that means
I'll get there eventually hopefully sure
but but that is a very important thing
and I've always felt like I don't care
what people think but at the same time I
deeply care if what my peers think and
my my men think we're dichotomy I think
that's a core value thing it's like you
have these core values and that's what
you care about you know what you think
about it what everyone else thinks but
and then anything beyond that it's just
superficial fluff like if you don't
match your socks and I think what that's
the key principle here the part that may
help bring this together for me is I
want to be doing the right thing yeah
right and so if I'm doing the right
thing and people say oh jock was that's
that's that's that's stupid what jock
was doing or he shouldn't be doing that
but I know in my heart I'm doing the
right thing yeah I'm gonna continue
doing I don't care what you think yeah
there you go
but at the same time if I know I'm doing
the right thing and other people are are
judging me that's gonna keep me in line
if I what let me rephrase it if I feel
like I'm gonna do the wrong thing hmm
I do care what people think yeah and I
don't want them to think all Jacko's
getting weak getting soft getting you
know whatever he's doing the wrong thing
he's making the wrong move
mm-hmm very strange that's that's the
dichotomy a leadership right or one of
them it's not really the dichotomy
leadership that's just a that's just a
dichotomy in life yeah like that now
there's a guy named lieutenant Compton
who kind of brakes a little bit and they
show up in them in the Band of Brothers
movie and they eat dick winners talks
about it here back to the book before
you go on I know you think I'm too hard
on lieutenant Compton for walking off
the line at Bastogne let me explain
myself buck that's the kind of confident
was nicknamed buck and he was-- walked
off the line buck was a great combat
lead
he was a superb platoon leader in
Normandy and Holland in fact I would say
he was one of the best at Bastogne he
broke after some of his friends were
seriously wounded in the constant
artillery barrages there is a danger of
getting too close to the men and Buck
crossed that line when you see your
friends getting maimed it makes it more
difficult to go on that's why I always
maintained a certain detachment from the
paratroopers and Easy Company am I too
harsh on buck maybe but a leader needs
to rise above fear the easiest thing to
do is quit and then the author asked why
didn't you crack and dick winners
responses on Pennsylvania Dutch I don't
quit I made a commitment moral courage
is based on physical fitness courage is
a combination of willpower and
determination and determination I was an
excellent physical shape I don't think
there was a man in the out that outfit
who's in better shape than I was and it
showed I had trained hard in England
after we finished training I would run
at night blackout conditions but I would
run then I'd come in and go to bed I was
in maximum shape that was the physical
side of things but there is a mental
aspect of stamina as well I've always
prided myself that I'd do my own
thinking I have my own philosophy I have
my own answers to the reasons things
have turned out in my life by taking
full accountably accountability for my
life I've been able to meet the
standards that I set for myself I don't
know any other way of saying it every
commander must take full accountability
for his actions stand up and be counted
as a commander you are accountable for
everything that your outfit does or
fails to do don't worry about who
receives credit when things go well
don't play the blame game in my case the
mantle of command provided me with the
courage to succeed
yeah extreme ownership that's what he's
talking about you know personal
accountability that's what he's talking
about being in great physical condition
that's what he's talking about that's
discipline you know I guess as we read
this and I you know I didn't read this
book until a week ago yeah on week ago I
read this book so it's not like I read
this book and said hey personal
accountability is the most important
thing about you know being a leader no
this guy came to the same conclusion in
World War two that I came to and
conclusion in my experience in the
military now he starts talking a little
bit about combat fatigue how much combat
fatigue there was in Normandy I
witnessed lots of stress some in Holland
much more Bastogne due to the intense
cold lack of sleep and inadequate
clothing in Belgium combat fatigue
reached astronomical proportions we had
spent seventy days in the frontlines in
Holland and didn't have time to recover
before we boarded the trucks to take us
to Bastogne on reflection I realized
what was happening and arrived in
Bastogne the men had been on the
frontline since Normandy men were
exhausted no hot food little sleep no
rest constant tension and intense
pressure from combat they were
physically exhausted inclement weather
and constant rain and snow made matters
even worse physical exhaustion leads to
mental exhaustion which in turn causes
men to lose discipline the loss of
self-discipline produces combat fatigue
over and over again over and over again
we hear that how important is discipline
it is the most important thing and if if
discipline is what gets people through
these situations through combat stress
through tension through bombs through
artillery through freezing-cold lack of
food lack of sleep imagine what
just wouldn't doing like a normal
person's life yeah back to the book how
can you possibly compare a man who's
been under just one concentrated
artillery bombardment for five minutes
to place like Bastogne where it could be
in the line for weeks or months in one
of Ambrose's books he states that
prolonged artillery bombardment will
break any soldier in civilian life of
course we refer to combat fatigue as a
mental breakdown that is exactly the way
it is in combat it's a mental breakdown
the intensity it becomes a problem for
me to express my feelings here but I'd
like to share it with you the intensity
of a fire or a heavy concentration to be
a leader you have to be able to
concentrate on that fire and move just
as soon as it stops or the last rounds
hit move get up start circulating among
your men is everybody okay let's get up
let's move keep your eye open for an
attack get their attention move among
your men as quickly as possible and
moving among them the fact that they see
you and they're talking to you they know
that you are there and you are talking
to them and it makes all the difference
in the world to know that you are not in
this thing by yourself
that's what officers must do break the
cycle of fear if a soldier is
concentrating on his own feelings and on
his own fear and he sees you moving
around he realizes that you're sharing
the burden with him that's why he can
then move so that's very important and
that's you know again that can apply to
combat that can apply to business people
are going to start panicking what are
they going to do and they start
panicking you and the leader as the
leader you can step up get out there
talk to people find out what's going on
tell them that we're gonna move show
them that you're not afraid and that you
are afraid but you're still functioning
lead by example plain and simple back to
the book courage will be spent if you
relax your standards
an undisciplined soldier feels old
isolated and alone maintain the
standards don't compromise your
integrity never get up give up don't
ever give up I love this right here
there is always one more thing that a
leader can do to improve his situation
and that of his command I always felt
that a leaders physical presence was
indispensable to unit cohesion and
morale this is why I've captain Sobel
failed so miserably leadership by
example always Trump's leadership by
fear there's always one more thing that
a leader can do to improve his situation
and that of its command is always one
more thing you can do and an
undisciplined soldier feels isolated and
alone they know they've given up that
self-respect how you gonna give it back
to them when your men are dying and you
do not you feel ashamed I don't know any
other way of saying it soldiers in war
certainly in World War two and I suspect
in every war are generally young men in
their prime they meet death daily and in
every form they fully realize the
hazards of their profession they take
chances because no young man expects to
die before middle age and the first
soldier dies that belief in immortality
is shattered as casualties mount and the
core of the unit grows fewer the
remaining soldiers grow even stronger
often shutting off replacement soldiers
they don't want to know the replacements
because they are often the first to die
when I saw one of my men wounded I was
happy that he had a ticket home soldier
killed in battle was at peace he had
lived his life among men whom he had
loved I took a degree of consolation and
knowing that my men had lived rather
than regretting that they had died
a soldier's real fear is not losing his
life in combat replacing his comrades in
jeopardy
that's why ordinary men were performed
in extraordinary ways to ensure that
their buddies survived so this is
another level of you know war when
you're actually and I never was at this
point by any stretch we're looking at
men that get wounded and saying oh lucky
him he's got to take it home we just
weren't under that knee that kind of
casualty level at all
so when guys were getting wounded it was
you know it was hard it was you didn't
feel like a lucky him he's got to take
it home because there wasn't enough guys
getting wounded to make you think that
way and not enough guys getting killed
to make you think that way small
percentage that's the region a whole new
level
back to the book if you've selected the
right personnel then a leader must
instill discipline I mean perfect
discipline as Patton once said
discipline is the soul of the army
general Washington said the same thing
when he described the Continental Army
in 1776 discipline is manifested in how
well a soldier keeps his uniform how
frequently cleans his weapon and the
pride he has in his unit Joe Hogan of
Easy Company speaks for all of us on the
subject of pride in Company II during an
argument with a soldier from another
company about whose company
better Joe said my company II will lick
your company in 15 minutes if you wait
until the guys who are AWOL come back
we'll do it in five minutes and this is
important unit pride leads to unit
discipline so again now we're going back
to the feelings that I had when I was a
young kid in the SEAL Teams total pride
in my platoon and this is funny cuz you
came like look the guys that are gone
right now they're a wall they're absent
without leave if nations you wait for
them to come back Nick that in five
minutes but you know I feel like this
this unit pride and unit discipline how
they go together it's like a gang yeah I
I don't know why I think of it this way
and I talked about this at the muster
it's like a gang mentality when you
start policing yourself up right when we
when I was a super tune we it wasn't our
bosses that were we're trying to keep us
in mind we kept ourselves in line you
didn't want to get outside you want to
do something wrong because we're gonna
get policed up by the boys the e5 mafia
is what we were so the e5 mafia that's a
real thing by the way the e5 mafia to
seal platoon you got the senior guys
there's like the platoon the platoon
chief the leading petty officer
those are those are like East 67th and
you got the assistant platoon commander
those those are like on the top four
those the guys that kind of run there's
actual leadership and then you got the
nugs and then in the middle of the pack
right there you got the e5 they're the
guys that are actually running things
and making things happen and the e5
mafia is what we call them and then Anna
sylveon under the e5 mafia that all
works together to make things happen but
with the e5 mafia if you've got a good
unit that e5 mafia they're policing up
everything that you don't need to as a
leader you just need to make sure that
they don't take it too far if you only
say you need to make sure that's it but
they're going to they're going to make
sure guys are doing the right thing
they're going to make sure that they're
performing well they're gonna make sure
that they're in good shape they're going
to make sure all those things
and this is an interesting quote what
you tolerate you condone so again
extreme ownership written by myself and
lace Bab and will a fab and wrote a line
in there it says it's not what you
preach it's what you tolerate and he
hadn't read this book and here it is
what you tolerate you condone to saying
the exact same thing
can you let standard start to slide you
that's what you're done that's the new
standard of course there's a little bit
more to leadership than what we've
talked about so far back to the book
leading in battle is the art of dealing
with human nature in the human condition
I can't speak of higher command but I
know a few things about leadership at
the small unit level leadership at all
levels wins Wars but soldiers at the
platoon company and battalion levels win
battles I think this is particularly
true in the National Army where soldiers
need to understand the reasons behind
the officers orders we have to know why
we're doing what we're doing what I have
succeeded
had I been promoted beyond battalion I
don't know I do know that I felt
comfortable at the small unit level this
is one reason why Easy Company holds
such a tender place in my heart I knew
the strengths and weaknesses of every
paratrooper I could rapidly ascertain
what I wanted to do and felt confident
that I could convince the men to do it
after commanding Easy Company in
Normandy in Holland I know that the men
felt comfortable and trusting their
lives to my care I'm not bragging
because it's not my nature to do so I'm
stating fact knowing that I would never
ask them to do anything that I wouldn't
do myself led to easy companies
confidence in me as a leader they knew
that I would never quit and then I would
do everything within my power to bring
them home after the war I'm proud when I
hear a paratrooper from Easy Company or
second Battalion remark about
my courage under fire my willingness to
share their hardships I told you once
that wars do not make great men but war
sometimes bring out the greatness in
good men human nature that's what it is
and you know that's sort of how I
describe this podcast now an exploration
of human nature and if you want to see
human nature reveal itself in its most
clearest form you have to go to war to
look at that or others very strenuous
situations harsh situations upon
returning from the war here's what major
winters had to say back to the book the
war changed me I returned to the states
bitter a different man than the young
man who had assisted in the Army in 1941
I was hardened when I returned first
impressions were more important than
they had previously been I looked at
things differently when you return from
a wartime environment you have to adjust
to society the life that you are going
to be sharing with others just to make a
living though I was comfortable in a
combat environment I wondered if I would
feel at home among civilized people who
wouldn't be able to understand how a
soldier thinks and feels I came to
understand that I would have to make
changes to be accepted into life at home
this takes time and it's never easy
while on the frontlines in prolonged
combat I often wondered about my friends
back in the States old friends I had
grown up with some of whom had avoided
coming over either by becoming
conscience and subject errs or working
in Warley related factories that the
federal government had declared
essential I understand everyone doesn't
have to share my belief that military
service is the only form of service in
wartime
but I took immense pride in my
to the war effort we who fought the war
were part of something noble military
service is an honor a privilege funny
thing is that when I finally returned
home I had no desire to pick up with
those friends who managed to skip the
whole thing I completely shut them out I
wouldn't come downstairs when they
knocked on the door even today when I
look at a man or woman I can't help but
judge them does he have leadership
capabilities would she be good in combat
does he or she have what it takes and I
think you know clearly when you come
home those are things I think everybody
goes through love you look at people
you're kind of judging people it
certainly will leave a mark I I'll tell
you I don't think there's enough
veterans now you know you're not gonna
be able to just hang around with
veterans it's not going to happen you
gotta you gotta understand and accept
the fact that not everyone served the
way you served that's just the way it is
and I don't I try to make sure that I
don't outwardly hold people to a higher
expectation and the other thing is I
think you have to walk a fine line and
you got to make sure you're not looking
down on people because they didn't
choose the path that you chose now world
war ii is different because or at least
appears to be different because it was
so easy so many people went on the path
of okay you know
December 7th happened I'm going to sign
up tomorrow today whatever and I think
that the way these wars that we've been
fighting have gone down it hasn't been
the same it's been different and I think
we veterans right now have to use some
caution before just shutting out
everyone else that that didn't serve the
way we did we'd be shutting out
basically you probably be shutting out
most the people in your lives most
most of my friends outside the SEAL
Teams there you know you get to got a
bunch of friends from Jitsu none of them
served I can't just shut them all out so
I think we have to be careful about that
as as veterans to make sure we you're
going to have those feelings understood
understand that there's more than that
and you've gotta you gotta accept other
things going on in the world besides
what we did another letter that dick
winners wrote to D at alman going back
to the book when you're an officer you
are responsible for the lives of
soldiers in your command you think about
kids like this one paratrooper I knew
well and you soon become old beyond you
years in the three years since I had
entered the army I urged a great deal it
seems as if college days and days of
civilian life when I did as I please are
long past I must have been it it must
have been a dream a small and short the
beautiful part of my life now all I do
is work work to improve myself as an
officer work to improve them as fighters
as men make them work to improve
themselves the result is I am old before
my time
not physically old but hardened to the
point where I can make the rest of them
look like undeveloped high school boys
old to the extent where I can keep going
after my men fall over and sleep from
exhaustion I can keep going as a mother
who works after her sick child an
exhausted child has fallen asleep old to
the extent where if it's a decision or
advice needed my decisions are taken as
if the wisdom behind them was infallible
yes I feel old and tired from training
these men to the point where they are
fishing fighters I hope it means that
some were
turn to those girls back home and again
the reason I put that in there is
because there's that's what that's
pressure right that's the certain amount
of pressure that a person that's been in
the military has felt and it's real that
pressure and his wife said dick fights
the Battle of the Bulge virtually every
night he had recurring nightmares
so even dick winners you know a very
thoughtful and squared away guy was
still living those nightmares virtually
every night his wife said dick also said
back to the book I know I did everything
within my power to ensure as many
soldiers made it home from the war as
possible but when you survive and your
soldiers don't you feel guilty it haunts
me to this day that I lived and so many
of my paratroopers died as the veterans
of Easy Company pass on I am reminded of
those who never returned from the war I
see their faces I can almost hear them
calling me
and again I think that everybody that
served and survived when your friends
and your brothers didn't you're always
going to have that and it's not going to
go away
and dick winners major dick winters died
January 2nd 2011 obviously they had a
memorial service the big memorial
service for him back to the book those
who remained alive voiced their sympathy
said former platoon sergeant William
Grenier who had lost a leg outside
Bastogne dick always said hang tough and
follow me when he said let's go he was
right in the front
he was never in the back a leader
personified he was the best commander we
ever had
we'd have followed him anywhere Edward
babe Heffron who served alongside
winners at Bastogne and who helped
liberate Hitler's Eagle's Nest added he
was one hell of a guy one of the
greatest soldiers I ever was under he
was a wonderful officer a wonderful
leader he had what you needed guts and
brains it took care of his men that's
very important Popeye Wynn added it
seemed as if he always made the right
decision he was a real soldier he was
one of the best it started with him
doing the right thing I don't know how
he survived the war but he did another
Easy Company veterans concurred noting
every one of us we'd follow him to hell
that's the type of guy he was
and also speaking at that ceremony was a
guy by the name of Eric Gendron see who
was the screenwriter one of the
screenwriters for Band of Brothers and
he was trying to get the screenplay and
the series to be as accurate as possible
and so he spent a lot of time with dick
winters and he got to know him very well
and I found what he said about dick
winters to be very important here we go
back to the book dick winters made it
his personal quest to excel
whether it was executing the perfect
pushup or training himself to run three
miles up and down Currahee Mountain this
pursuit was his private tool his
solution and it was that solo effort
that obsessive clarity and pure
determined self-contained purpose that
his men observed and that caused them to
follow when he said simply follow me not
just from that hedgerow in Normandy and
across that field and Holland under
enemy fire but follow my example follow
my commitment and we'll get through this
then we will succeed
dick winters was laid to rest his family
plot in the Evangelical Lutheran
Cemetery in Ephrata Pennsylvania the
Saturday following his death and his
gravestone reads simply Richard D
winters world war two hundred and first
Airborne 1918 to 2011
kindig winners before he died said I am
the man I am today because of Easy
Company Easy Company made me as I
reflect upon my life since the war I can
honestly say that it has been a lifetime
search for men like those I knew an easy
company
I haven't found too many I don't think I
know braver soldiers that Joe Toye go
gone here Floyd Talbert I live with
these guys every day I mourn when they
pass Carwood Lipton died in December
2001 his death struck me particularly
hard so did bull Randleman Lipton didn't
live to see the acclaim Easy Company
received when the miniseries was
released I try not to think of the bad
times anymore
I think mostly of the good times the
emotion will always be there
and no dick winner said that war brings
out greatness and men and he also
realized that war makes you appreciate
your country
the major winners before he died said
well it probably sounds strange to you
but when I brought easy company that
Utah beats so we could board the LST to
return to England on July 11th 1944 I
saw that beach for the first time with
that vast Armada of ships as far as the
eye could see in every direction seeing
the American flag fluttering over that
Beach I felt weak in the knees and tears
filled my eyes suddenly that flag meant
something different than it ever had
before I've never looked at our flag
since without that memory in mind now
I'm an old man but that feeling has
never left me
and finally then I always say that war
is awful
and war is a nightmare
but or does certainly make you
appreciate life
then dick winners certainly appreciated
the rest of his life
then he said this I sit here in this
house and I gaze out the window I see
flowers and the birds I behold the
wonder of nature everything seems so
beautiful but that wraps up that book
everything seems so beautiful and you
know over the past couple of weeks I've
been travelling a bunch and meeting a
lot of different people businesspeople
workers police and firefighters and
active-duty military and veterans just
people and we people we get caught up in
all kinds of chaos and mayhem mayhem
from the past we get caught up in that
about what we should have done or what
we should have left undone and we feel
this pressure about the future about
what we should do or what we shouldn't
do or where we're going and how would
you get there and I get that I get that
I understand it I feel it do
life is hard life is hard and if you
aren't careful it will grind you down
and you know I talked about detachment a
lot from a leadership perspective and we
talked about it today and it's certainly
important but it's also a tool for your
mind and for your sanity step back step
back and look around not just to see
what your next move is and where to head
next and what to focus on but step back
to look around and and see life this
life your life not surrounded by the
pressure and the war and the failures
and the violence and the nightmares and
the mistakes and the grind not that life
but life as it is as it is without our
intervention
a blessing a journey a short little bit
of time on an incredibly fast-moving
sphere of amazement where if you can
detach and step back and look for a
moment you'll see that like dick winter
said everything seems so beautiful
and I think that's all of God for the
night so echo Charles yeah some lessons
look yeah
very impactful for me and a big reminder
for me we worked heavily with the first
of the 506 Band of Brothers in the
battle Ramadi we had a the Delta platoon
commander and a group of his guys spent
a whole time over there and what an
incredible bunch of soldiers they were
just incredible the the impact that they
had on the battlefield the leadership I
saw at every level level and whenever I
think of the band of brothers my first
thoughts when I think of the band of
brothers isn't about dick winters it
isn't about the series it isn't about
the books my first thought of the band
of brothers is the first of 506
battalion that we were honored to work
with in the battle Ramadi and one of my
platoons worked intently with the entire
time and so for their service and
sacrifice we I am eternally thankful for
what they did and what they taught us
and
for us being alongside them was real
humbling
really yeah you mentioned how how like
in all these books and all these lessons
that discipline is like so important and
but there's time you mentioned like
imagine or imagine how important it is
or how beneficial whatever it could be
just in everyday life remember that
yesterday yeah that's that's crazy in
the more books like this so we go over
whatever that message like becomes more
and more clear because you know like you
get um like creative guys you know but
they don't have discipline kind of thing
or you get super discipline guys but
they don't have creativity or you know
yeah kind of but every once in a while
you'll get you'll find a person or
you'll notice a person who does bring
them together you know and you see the
results that you see what kind of
productivity or you just you just see
the results in one where they're you
know like these get like fighters or you
know I don't know like anyone doing
absolutely so man it's crazy how and you
know if you're like naturally gifted or
whatever that's something you in a way
not likely
I don't know what that's like yeah but I
mean it let's say you notice someone and
you see it in all these different fields
as well or where someone that's got a
lot of natural talent yeah they don't
they don't have this because essentially
through upbringing whatever the just
environment they don't need it really
you know they don't eat it like just get
away with it because that's another
talent they get away with it yes exactly
I mean I think we hear that a lot this
idea that you know talent it doesn't
mean anything if you don't have the
discipline to make things happen and and
a person that's highly disciplined will
outperform someone that might be more
talented yeah I'll bet lovely yes I'll
oh yeah and it was all day long too
strong I am the beginning in the
beginning and yes exactly I feel like
eventually um the discipline is this
thing that's just going to carry you
through so and I thought I just thought
that was super important where you were
like imagine if this if you apply this
to everyday life because everyday life
essentially
us anyway it's like a straight-up luxury
yeah it is and here's what's important
about what you're saying is is this fact
that the reason that these guys had to
have discipline is because if they
didn't have discipline they would die
yeah if they didn't have discipline they
would be overrun if they didn't have
discipline they would they would starve
they would just die they would die you
know they have to have this one and your
point is in this world in this life in
2017 living in the first world you don't
have to have discipline at all yeah and
you'll still survive and you might even
do okay yeah sure just imagine yeah just
imagine if you apply the discipline to
your life where you'll end up yeah and
how much better off you'll be and how
much more you can do with your life the
one life you have by the way or you can
do with that life if you just have the
discipline and work hard and get after
it
yeah and you see it in little pockets to
like remember when you're a kid and like
I'm gonna say well save my money for
this I don't know comic book I don't
know I'm gonna save my money you don't
even have an income by the way but
somehow you save all your money like
that little corridor that you find does
it all you know you I'm save that I'm
gonna save that because you have this
kind of and in a way like the discipline
kind of forms itself around that goal so
you know what it is like you know what
that means you know so it's real like
that's a real thing you shouldn't you
shouldn't regard it as some ambiguous
thing that I know it's not like not all
I'm so many randomly crazies hanging at
all yeah it's real straightforward yeah
I think that was one of the first
podcast we did when I said something
along one to like you know what you need
to do yeah look we all know do it should
be doing I think that was the first
there's not too many people that a loss
that are going on just not sure how to
do this no they know exactly what these
we know exactly what yeah I know exactly
what I should be doing tell you what it
is distractions too many distractions
and distractions are literally
everything
there's industries of just distractions
that's the whole industry like TV TV
industry of destroy Hugh Janus of TV TV
can be a confession
because there's educational stuff on me
um divided I'm just saying like Cedar
Point the entertainment industry and I'm
not saying these industries of
destructions or bad things I'm not
saying that I'm just saying distractions
are what get in the way of I know for
lack of a better term like your your
goal yeah and well we're talking about
the very fact of some of your discipline
can be used to create things that are
actually distracting them if you will if
your goal is to create some artistic
piece whether it's a movie whether it's
music whether it's whatever that that's
a distracting thing but that's not that
doesn't mean that it's negative that we
want to make that happen yes there's
people that will find something I mean
the reason you want to create something
is I guess you create it for yourself
but then the reward is when other people
say yes I get something out there too
recognition for me appears yeah for sure
yeah and when I say distractions I do in
regards to goal it's a relative thing
meaning like you're distracted from your
path of the goal I agree with you yeah
but there's also just just mentally just
just weakness just the easy path I
should say right the discipline bonds
art the the easy path that anyone wants
to jump on when your alarm clock goes
off a lot right I've talked about these
things a million times that's what the
problem is
the problem isn't even distraction the
problem is just a lack of will to do
what you need to do right the direction
can add to that that's about that's a
part of it what we do is we take we take
our the path of least resistance and
then we throw distraction on top of that
for instance when you open up your
computer because you've got to write a
book and instead of stroking the word
processing code I'm just going to check
the interwebs real quick distracted yeah
you're distracted there goes 45 minutes
you look in the Internet is the Internet
of the mind a time warp Oh at times it
disappears on the internet there's a lot
of distractions on there yeah we're sure
and really what I mean by distraction is
you have this long term goal right your
goal is your payoff your long-term
payoff so so the distractions really are
these little short-term payoffs that
drag you that diss track you so that's
what I put the destruction eliezer you
broke that out for me right right but
right getting off the track exactly
right so the weakness will let those
distractions kind of take hold
sure but so yeah they work hand in hand
for sure so so if you can sit because
again that saving money for comic books
thing so consider that as the goal so
the distractions are going to be the
candy that you want to buy or the you
know I don't you play dice with your ad
on whatever the distractions is in
regards to that specific pack I like
echoes world right now like playing dice
with your friends saving some comic
books like 1960 so I like it
you know back but either way like the
distractions they're relevant so eat
when I say okay the distractions are
there when I say there's industries of
distractions again I'm not saying these
are bad things they are bad things if
they're distracting you from your goal
so you need also to gold think about it
sometimes you just need to let your mind
take a rest yeah you need one of the oh
I gotta fucking I just flew home from
like I've been on the road while all
over the world did the muster did a
bunch of speeches did some consulting
was all over the place on the plane the
whole time and I flew home from the East
Coast
one was that set a couple days ago and
when I flew I haven't done this in
forever I flew home I watched a movie I
really I just did a total distraction
because I said you know what I can't I'm
not I'm not I'm not in the game right
now like I need my brain you sneeze you
shut off yeah do something which I don't
like to do which is you can either do
two things I look at it you need to
consume or you can produce right I want
to be producing I want to be putting
together I want to be writing I want to
be thinking I want to be right reading
for the podcast prepping that's what I
want to be doing what are you producing
something consuming is I'm just
absorbing what someone else made yeah
right I'm just going to absorb this
absorb this absorb this a lot of times
it is garbage so but I flew home had a
long flight know like you know what I
need to check out I need to check out
right now just do nothing so I watched
two movies dig it to move would EULA we
got a little a good at the two movies I
watched the first one was not Heartbreak
Ridge
it's the new movie that just came out
about daus that Mel Gibson directed
what's it called oh no there's a big
successful movie consciousness objector
world war two he wins the Medal of Honor
or he's awarded the Medal of Honor
hmm so that was a good movie you know
it's a world war two movie I liked it
it's not in my opinion five star but it
was good it was entertaining
sir he told the story and then after
that I watched Zoolander that was when I
was going to the full blood pressure
good anyway why do Lander yeah because
it's a hilarious movie I have a buddy in
the teams that we nicknamed Mugatu sure
yeah because you know he would go crazy
so we had to call me doctor yeah and
yeah that was just a funny movie I just
decompress yeah I don't do that very
often
hey you know the grind is always
happening but I'll just had to take a
little detachment what was the name of
that movie with there's not famous
actors I guess there's one who's a
really funny guy anyways there's a good
movie yeah so techno what the sort of
question is is that really a distraction
so you know like a football game or a
movie or something that that you're not
doing to put you you know more forward
on your path or whatever but if you're
taking your if you're taking a break is
that a distraction
like if I'm lifting I do a workout and
then I go recover from that way I read
oh is that a diss track I don't
distraction it I should have tried to do
yeah not good
no oh yeah and your mind I was done slow
Japs out so a distraction is more of an
idea more the concept you know so like
you definitely think that it is just
like how you said when you open your
computer and the whole internet is there
to distract on one way or another yeah
um that's a distraction you know where
you can eat like even if I have a book
if my goal is to finish some video but
meanwhile I have this book that's real
informative and it's um and I'm like you
know that book seems real unreal in the
mood to read that book that's a
distraction even though it's a good
thing you know so the detection is like
the idea so look you know what are the
common goals I want to get in shape I
want to UM you know be a better husband
or
life or I want to do better at work on a
learn monetary all the stuff you're
better at jiu-jitsu get better you do to
all the stuff you can get distracted by
these other things you know before I I
don't know read I'm a surf Instagram or
something like that that's a distraction
you know and now which is my original
point is the reason or one of the
reasons that we don't apply this extreme
discipline as it's outlined in these
books here is B is one of the reasons is
because we have literally infinite
amount of distraction okay well there's
also no consequence or I shouldn't say
that the consequence is invisible yeah
consequence you don't say you don't say
hey if I would have had discipline I
would reach this ultimate potential you
just okay with not reaching that an
ultimate potential and you're just like
learning and putting microwavable
popcorn in and watching a movie do
you've been doing it the whole time as
well hey I know here I'm good I and you
know what it was a good movie and a
popcorn tasted good they don't know what
I mean that's the wrong answer
yeah you don't recognize what your
potential is and so you're just okay
with this kind of half potential you
don't reach your potential and since you
don't know it any other thing it's hard
to see it's hard to see how that
long-term affects you yeah I got yes
just one bag of popcorn is just one
movie yeah but you did that three times
this week yeah you know that's that's
not 30 times you know I'm not in the
past ten yeah you could write 30,000
words no more than that yeah you're
right about thousand words an hour well
a good way to look at it and I think I'm
gonna said this where it's not like a
moment-to-moment looking to the Future
kind of thing you should look at it but
in the way of in the sense of looking at
it in the past so let's say you consider
the last one year or two years right and
let's say I wanted to play better guitar
something good goal yeah I have that
goal I always fail at it there you go so
you look at it in this way where you
don't say okay if I spend an hour a day
um you know practicing guitar and you
know in a year I'll be better
you don't necessarily look like that you
can but a good way to look at it or
helpful with is if you look at it last
year where dang if I if I would have
played an hour a day
right now right now as I'm sitting here
with you right now I'd be Delphic guitar
you know kind of like that so you kind
of get the wrong in my experience I've
got this feeling of like wasted time you
know you know that feeling worth like
dang I got I got to play catch-up now
that's a little bit more compelling I
think sometimes it can be there so he
scream about it that way too I think
that helps maybe maybe not
sleep either help speaking of help and
potential Oh both actually got a double
gravitational you need help by with
supplementation if you're working out so
man how you said you can't not work out
I think especially nowadays like you
could because your life to
probability-wise is cruising you're
cruising physically where you know you
go to office because really a life is
physically easy right now you're a tank
it's easier and easier even if it's not
easier right now next year generally
speaking it's going to be easier you
know like even like so I'm brushing my
teeth like I do every week or whatever
and once a week whether or not yes and
so I've the regular toothbrush you know
I'm sure there's all kinds of little
micro technologies in the toothbrush but
I start to think Madness there have you
know this is the old school thing
there's automatic toothbrushes actually
my brother told me about this too so
let's do this automatic you know
electric toothbrush sells like super
dope and I highly recommended it it's
like $89 all this stuff and I'm thinking
dang something as basic as brushing your
teeth is way easier now way easier got a
machine to do it that's that's really
the whole narrative with everything
point being physically alright push
yourself because you're not gonna have
to push it you get a real force you yeah
yeah your environment is starting to
work more and more against you
in regards to physical activity so my
point being you didn't work out
yeah I was going to say that's a real
straightforward thing work out yeah but
I feel like it I mean maybe for you you
know to be like yeah it seems obvious
you know they call that the curse of
knowledge you know
when you're you're like so advanced in
this one thing that you forget how it is
to not be advanced now that's your like
I have forgotten what it's like to not
be advanced in terms of trying to
explain to people why they were I think
it's pretty self-evident anybody why are
you to workout not you're wrong
yeah okay think about this and I think
but and I thought about this one like
okay you know when you go into a jujitsu
gym okay you're different so you make
you very well not even understand this
this might not compute with you but if
you walk into a jujitsu gym and this
applies to even a regular 24-hour
Fitness gym if you've never been in
there before you've ever worked out
that's a really intimidating thing you
come in if one's looking at me I don't
know how to use the machines I don't
know how to work out like it was look at
me judging me I'm dumb it is not my
element all this stuff that's
intimidating you know okay but it's real
what I'm saying you know how you say
like you probably don't know about that
because you don't you have the curse of
knowledge in regards to like physical
activity working out you know all that
stuff and then the pain that comes with
it man I date I understand but that's
even more of a reason to work out
physical condition anyway Yury glad you
did if you don't work out just jump in
there jump in go to the gym last year if
you would have started working out you
know how dope you'd be right now wait
Oprah then you are if in the event you
didn't start last I sure seems like
anyway while you work out you joints
might be kind of sore I know this from
experience take krill oil my
father-in-law turned me on to it
actually technically didn't successfully
turn me on to Italy until he tried he
tried and you know I didn't see the
light until Jocko turned me onto it so
now I'm turning everyone else onto it
hopefully successfully krill oil is I'm
not going to go into a whole deep thing
here but it's for your joint so if you
get joint pain we just would
degeneration over time you get older dig
it
krill oil bring you back still function
it's kind of like your joint joint
search like always warm now not like to
the touch warm but like warm like ready
for action you see I'm saying
anyway krill oil I ain't even say by who
huh if you don't know on it that's the
whole company and they have they don't
have just krill oil they have other
stuff too they are mr. Veeck
yeah perform it I
I recommend shrimp deck by the way big
time especially if you're going for
performance yeah if you're gonna go
train jiu-jitsu with Andy Taylor Dean
Craig Baker yes Greg train echo Charles
just take take the shrimp we know what
sport the a stream Josh for takes three
of them ah is that so that's the
recommended I didn't know that and then
I read it yeah I'd like one day I just
read the instructions for no way I was
like wonder if I take 12 of these things
about me get more tech 1 when I did say
three cuz I've been taken to a fro sorry
took three talked a little bit legit
yeah I always take a curry and never let
down and again that's for the
performance so if I'm just cruising if
I'm just taking a walk around the block
or two I take the shrimp tech I'm not
going to feel it as much as if I jump in
jiu-jitsu rounds you know ya know you
dig it when I have to perform a
situation yeah big time me too you take
stream tech immune not to be confused
with and I've taken shrimp tech
amusement when I go massive travel yeah
you can always planes well people
everyone's sick coughing sneezing yeah
it's all nasty oh you and I do just go
ahead and take some shroom tech immune
consider that something different it's
the yellowish it's a ligand that a label
the green tooth of the whatever you're
eating is more yellow yeah I think the
ingredients will just say the
ingredients you know I take vitamins
please actually but I'm a big travel
vitamin C shrimp check immune I here
zinc is a good one - that's what I hear
I've taken zinc before to try and
overcome a cold but I wasn't very uh you
know convinced yeah yeah I can power I
will powers in vitamin C though if I
feel like some kind of a disease coming
on
yeah power the vitamin C it's kind of a
good thing where you take this um shroom
tech immune it like you know you know
that they were like okay does vitamin C
help okay check it does zinc and I don't
know I didn't read the ingredients like
you either didn't thought were a bus or
whatever but I read the effects yeah
okay got to raise my immune system going
to need that playing a bunch of dirty
people
not always
many neezy sir sneezing on everyone
coughing on everyone yeah and and by the
way because I'm gonna go talk to people
I can't be going on
I'm Jack oh yeah I can't do that I have
to actually be able to talk yeah
coughing singing yes you constable today
me it's awful if you if you sneeze or
cough when you're on a mic in front of a
big group of people not cool or if you
keep doing it yeah kind of turned out
good of you should wanna calm you know
the good stuffs in the elkay yes on it
calm you want 10% off all this stuff on
it calm slash Jocko and here's the thing
we just talked about right now we talked
about krill oil shrimp exports from tech
immune out of range okay yeah alphabet
bro we could go on all night with this
because of all the good stuff that he
levels into this I did you watched me
actually well yeah yeah eating hate it I
had alpha brain today and I was thinking
you took it but then when you wanted
that long story about something and I
was sort of wondering maybe he didn't
take his out for breaking oh Dan Dan
when I wrapped it up you were like
they're you all over the whole time oh
your alphabet I didn't see it alpha
bring that statement made me say to you
are an alphabet today just gives you a
complete your the whole deal right there
I'm not gonna tell you
I'll read it back without an echo story
and then when it comes to closure you go
okay get some of that good CA could take
lead take my lead example you understand
what I'm saying the so alpha brain if
you don't know because we haven't talked
about it as much as yeah I feel like as
far as its role in our lives my life you
know speak for me so where you take it
neutral is called neutral pick it's
basically brain food brain food
supplements you know like did to make
your brain know what I'm going to talk
about it to you because I've been taking
mostly on it
mostly alpha brain in the pack in the
powder taste good
yeah the peach and the spice place I've
been taking it in that more than I I'm
going to actually ran out of the pills
yeah the capsules wait so you let you'd
prefer the capsules you're saying well
sometimes the capsules a little bit more
convenient right yeah yeah but I like it
like if I'm doing an event or I'm gonna
go on a podcast yeah and I didn't I
wanted to build a bamned makes himself a
brainy and
brainy see my euros in a very doing a
bunch of stuff now mix it up a little
ritual you know like when you brew tea
it's like not so extreme anyway either
way they're both the same deal and
they're called nootropics proven by the
way I'm not just saying it was good for
me so you should take it not the same
that now when you you you say that yeah
but to me that means more to me then I
don't know why but like when you say oh
it's a double triple blind placebo blah
blah blah control but yeah I would
rather have like someone that I know say
bro I'm telling you take this stuff like
I did with Grillo know for you yeah yeah
yeah it was more important than reading
a bunch of facts about it yeah yeah and
that takes someone that you know and
they're saying look man give it a little
crack yeah it rusts me on this one and I
think most people have that in one way
or another not with everything but yeah
like if you recommend a movie or
something like that and then meanwhile
look at the reviews the reviews are like
super good but then you're like eh it
was junk because this because of that
it's like it's an Iron Man shape being
so long you know we're right in the
classic 90s con it's at 90s comedy what
kind of mood is jockle in when i goes if
nineties call with the lender plan yeah
that's just ridiculous but see how busy
was but I like oh it's Owen Wilson and
that really no bill oh yeah sorry I'm
yeah in Ben I like I like that guy Owen
Wilson he's family I like him because he
comes across as very truthful in the way
he says yeah like almost naive yeah yeah
yeah you just like seems like a good
dude and you gonna keep you from dying
out well yeah I just kind of got this
air about him that's kind of hair heavy
yeah yeah yeah it's interesting
nonetheless back to the Alpha brain I
think that when they prove it I think
certain people certain types of like
mindsets or whatever kind of more
gravitate towards that like they're like
okay that's cool that it worked for you
but that could have been Lucy that could
have been this that could have been your
mood that day or whatever if I'm going
to commit to this I want some on some
hard sacks
some people that's up so boom you got
hard facts as well as a legitimate
recommendation because I was taking this
even before you know the podcast and
stuff so I was into it nonetheless alpha
brain that's a good one
bunch of other cool stuff if you're into
protein powder a good clean protein
powder on there all the salt would work
out stuff too by the way I got a bunch
of kettlebells their primal bells legend
L the artistic one they're dope look at
my Instagram there's some on there
anyway that is a good way to support
yourself help yourself
maintain the workouts physical activity
all that stuff so you can be successful
in that way I don't think there's any
excuse anymore I def Pharrell don't also
good way to support really good way to
support Amazon click-through when you go
and get the book conversations with
major dick winters go to the websites
listed there what you know cover and
click through there boom so basically
it's an amazon click to buy through
amazon amazon click through before you
do your shopping click through the
website amazon boom supports the podcast
small action big reaction because the
click there only takes what three
seconds I think we can turn the maximum
really so you know Kim from USA
three-section
seconds and then the reaction is massive
support for this podcast that's a good
way I'm son click through to the website
Jacobite Escom or I think it's on jockle
store calm as well just go to jackal
podcast calm
click through before you do your amazon
shopping also subscribe to the podcast
on itunes if you haven't already
stitcher google play all these other
podcasting providing platforms also on
youtube if you don't mind the video
version of this podcast below youtube
watch it there it's kind of cool and get
ads that other blare of experience yeah
everyone seems to do that when there's a
guest yeah because they don't know who
that person is they know what you look
like they know what I look like
most most yeah most people well if
they're listening to podcast eventually
they know what you look like they know
what I look like
yeah and so there's no reason sometimes
although sometimes you can see like when
certain subjects come up and there's
maybe some intensity in the podcast and
more people watch it knows whatever
pretty mellow podcast and we're just
talking about whatever we're talking
about maybe not everyone feels the need
to go to youtube but when a guest comes
on people want to see what that person
looks like and there's usually some more
animated interactions yes - yeah big
time yeah man so if you're into that you
know what it'd be cool if you made a
little clip of when Tim Kennedy was on
and I I read a question from the
audience was something along the lines
and I said I said you know hey you know
they took away bayonet training boot
camp and Tim can disgust me god damn it
that's my favorite parts of a podcast
ever but we need again that I want I
would really appreciate it if you'd make
that clip even if it was like 12 seconds
long but just yeah just 12 seconds long
it would be worth having on there
because everyone should know that that's
a travesty to say stop doing bayonet
courses it in farming boot camp you got
it some people if they don't hear this
exact part thing we kind of confused but
hey I think they'll appreciate it I
think so oh they'll hear it
yeah it'll dig it fully but there's good
animation yeah no he's getting crazy
yeah match is fun and really in general
just say YouTube that's an added like I
said in that added visual layer you know
if you're down for it sometimes people
you know you put it on your tea let's
say you in your grudge you know you're
working out or you're you know it's on
the TV it's kind of like you're in the
conversation a little bit more it feels
like it and also if people subscribe to
the YouTube channel then when they can
sign up where if you make an excerpt
right then they can get that cool like a
good living is it's much easier to share
an excerpt from the podcast than it is
to share an audio I don't even know how
to share audio piece of a podcast I
don't know how to do that it probably
can't be done probably that's why we
have the YouTube so yeah go ahead
subscribe to that one and speaking of me
mention the excerpts yeah you put some
excerpts you can if you don't want to
share or you anticipate the disperses
not gonna listen to two and a half hours
of a podcast when you share it you just
get the little lesson you know that you
want to share okay how to you know
approach college didn't what everyone
yeah that's a problem um cuz everybody
that went to college already wishes they
had that when they went to college yeah
so when they you know when they
encounter someone who's gonna you know
go to college their kids or nephew
neighbor whatever boom they have some
advice directly from Jocko anyway so
yeah you can you share that subscribe to
YouTube that's the point there subscribe
to youtube if you want and if you want
to support and you know if you want you
can sign up for a little alert when I
upload something on there I enough those
alerts you can get out very pretty
stoked I see something coming through
like a little present you know yeah so
YouTube good one um also chalk away the
store it's called Jaakko store Jaakko
store calm you know if you want t-shirts
and whatnot discipline equal freedom the
one that simply says get after it on the
front that seemed to have gone over
pretty well I'd say well and also it
seems worth noting that we now offer the
victory MMA shirt the jockey uniform
that I wear all the time field I wear it
when I record the podcast I wear it all
time tweet you know obviously because we
have our gym yeah we have a lot of
t-shirts are they are Jim's name on it
and so I wear that t-shirt lot yeah and
I always have yeah and then I I didn't
intentionally do it all the podcast in
the beginning I just happened to be
wearing it through or three times yeah
and then someone said is that the only
shirt Jaakko wears yeah and at that
point I said y-yes ago Noah you're like
the guy on the fly remember the movie
the fly yeah and the lady's like what
was African she's like hey is that your
only said it clothes or something like
that and she sees in his closet that
they're all the same oh yeah that is me
that yeah yeah like I like have things
are the same but it people would come
and ask me hey where can I get the
t-shirt work I get the t-shirt so now we
did it on the Jaakko store strangely
they didn't even have them at Victory no
I don't come and be like hey we want to
do a thing that our original goal this
is an original this is the original
victory MMA t-shirt
and we had to reproduce it yeah well she
had to reissue
yeah and I'll just open its own respect
right yeah it is
so I'm trying to think like is that
enough it's not because it's the exact
same design yeah it's actually like
literally the exact same like design
same file right yeah boom so now you get
that one if you want it now you can
represent represent big time it's good
it's interesting because yours are like
old school so they kind of have like a
fade to them yeah I know anyway we just
know they're like oh we mean look sure
beaming I'm claiming to grab a couple of
those too by the way right well just
because I was running low when I would
have other things in my yeah what's that
called when you have clothes my wardrobe
yeah yes see
good thinking chuckle anyway chocolate
or calm check those out some other new
stuff stuff things items on there let me
talk about this mug I'm going to take
too much time because we've been you
know we've been going at it so this
travel mug right here so you know how
you know at home you know you have your
cup didn't they yeah but you know what
I'm talking about the one that you you
know what I have actually my wife once
she searched forever to get me a cup
that I liked that she found it yeah and
then she went to Target and bought you
know it does nothing there's big giant
plastic but feel like glasses whatever
that is I'm not really core something
that can't break but you can but they
they feel good in your hands so I have a
bunch of those but apparently it's
getting replaced yes so it's strangely I
had the same thing well I was on the
same search so I just want what what I
arrived at my favorite cup was pink
because they didn't have any other
colors it was pink but it was big it was
like maybe like 24 outs like big cup
that's what I used for everything news
pink whatever that meant nothing your
your color blue better manhood yeah man
compared to compared to the
functionality the pink was nothing oh
but here's the thing it could barely
feel it like colder you know the kind
like you put it in but it was like kind
of stuck you'd have to fine but it that
was the cop that was the best one you
use any other cop you just I don't know
how you doing that I'm gonna get to that
so but you know what I mean though so
you know exactly I mean we're you know
you have your cup I know words like it
could be dirty there can be cups
everywhere
all available you're like no I'm gonna
go ahead wash this you know and I'm
these my cup that's it
this one okay we'll talk about this this
mug it's technically what
travel tumbler right ben-hur to whatever
and I'll come to the top of it though
but you take all the top boom that's a
cup to organ out anomaly for conducive
to just using it as a cut you know how
if you have like thread in there to
screw on at Thomas Freddie's like yeah
it's like a thing anyway
and that's not to mention the look
black-on-black what they call it murder
doubt you've heard that expression
murder doubt no trick Google if you have
time Google murder doubt Cadillac a car
what it is it's a flat matte painting
with black wheels so it's like basically
all black reticulum it's all black so
that's this thing is murdered out
technically some flat black matte with
like the glow go the 4:34 and the
discipline extreme is like shiny black
rhino block very nice very nice so and
that's just a design so function wise
perfect 30 ounces not 24 30 straight up
and it what is it BPA free all that so
you don't get poisoned over time come on
bro that's a big thing and also okay and
here's the impressive part when I
ultimately was like dang like impressed
I guess is like a technology has kind of
been around but I didn't know because I
had that plastic cup you know whatever
this it'll keep it'll separate the
temperatures from inside and outside so
the inside temperature won't leak to the
outside meaning it keeps like if you
have ice and cold stuff in here bro
means it's insulated it'll yeah but it's
insulated in a special crazy way if you
and this is with no top on by the way
you fill it up with ice or ice water you
know is what I did one time I finished
like knows maybe three quarters so some
water in there and I just I kind of left
it went to bed the next day I looked at
it and the ice was still in there and
yeah sure that doesn't mean that much
but as far as proving how it keeps the
temperature wow that's a lot
straight up also it doesn't like sweat
you know when you have a hold on it on
it yet if it's on your desk you're
working yeah yeah screw some stuff up
hot day whatever humid it's like yet
doesn't even do that doesn't do that at
all one time
hose outside the pool whatever cream ice
water actually chocolatey cool we'll get
to that too but so you know I leave it
there and it's in the Sun and I grab it
and I'm like oh my this is going to be
totally melted because I'm feeling it
the cup physically feeling the outside
of the cup and it's straight-up hot the
Sun is beaming on it's hot I look inside
I still the full on ice not even melted
at all well I'm telling you you replays
always copy that you're at the route I'm
done I'm telling you right now when you
replace this Cup you're going to find
all these benefits to it above and
beyond just the dope look and size and
it fits in your cup holder straight up
see how it's like the shape yeah cool
alright next next thing I feel like we
could talk about it over a little war
unless it advised or you like it I'm
glad you liked it I like it too
an exam first I'm utilizing it actually
and I'm impressed
but I see you still I see reading
getting down with this cup mug for a
long time can thoroughly impressed
anyway so yeah we got something we got
that on the taco store taco store calm
we got it on there also should we talk
about the warrior kid shirts you can
talk about that right there on there too
weird kid shirts youth sizes for your
kids boom there it is very very cool
warrior kids out there there's some
layers and now on to that I just found
out by the way your control the colors
of my gosh yeah yeah it's just don't
worry about that so check out again
chuckle sorta calmness and rash guards
on their new rash guards out maybe
they're out hoodies
kind of getting into like a spring I
think maybe summer pretty soon so these
might not be as applicable
either way they're on renew start
prepping the winter hoodies that I'm
going to be more in charge of this time
sure that they're heavier more powerful
yeah because you're thinking New England
winter yeah I'm say I'm colliding here
in Chicago in Minnesota and Iowa and I
think is Kauai over here doesn't Kauai
would he wear a shirt much less a
sweatshirt Brad that does my whole point
you're like hoodies
crowd what is that yeah you know what it
was actually my wife knows who these are
so I just consulted with her nonetheless
chuckles Darkon got some cool stuff on
their travel mugs all shirts cool shirts
support that way and you know you get a
little item represent in the wild boom
also support yourself with this one
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is which I know you already do
but if you don't it's an album with
tracks no music Jocko on there and these
tracks are useful these are utility what
you call functional tactical tracks to
help you stay on the path we talked
about getting distracted some people
they'll get distracted by comfort you
know like the path the path has income
is riddled with discomfort riddled and
sometimes after a while that that
discomfort can get to certain people at
certain times so what this psychological
warfare album does is it keeps you on
the path so for example you want to wake
up every day early that one day you're
distracted by the comfort of hitting the
snooze button getting ten more 20 more
minutes of sleep that's bad that's a
distraction that's a deviation from the
path listen to psychological war from uh
what's the number number one I think
doing nothing good after get up and get
a listen to that what it is your alarm I
dare you to hit snooze dare you
jock will just tell you practically in a
practical pragmatic way why you should
not hit the snooze boom um I would say
with 100% certainty that you will not
hit the snooze and you will stay on the
path and that goes for all these other
things deviating from diet deviating
from pushing yourself going to workout
deviating from going to the gym in the
first place going exactly right or if
you have like this procrastination
situation
oh man that's that's the main one that
you don't like how you're always like I
should I need to do this I should do
this just stop doing it yeah
procrastination is pretty much the thing
that's going to keep you from doing it
nonetheless if you procrastinate this a
got a little solution for you too anyway
psychological warfare
jakka Lily look for it on iTunes or
Amazon music by the way good that's
pretty cool also while you're on Amazon
you can get this book that we just
covered today conversations with major
dick winters Jaco white tea is also
available on Amazon if you don't want a
drink
oh so does you know which no one should
be drinking sodas at all you don't need
them they're actually horrible for you
but remember when we're eating sushi in
New York and busted out the coke yeah I
was oh I was gonna actually just I did I
was surprised I thought that you weren't
gonna be my friend anymore innit like
you realize I couldn't believe it
so anyways echo has this tradition great
wishes to me he sounds like a shiver
coated ally yes that when he eats sushi
he has a glass bottle of coke so he hate
that I overcame my hatred for him the
best I could it's kind of when I was
talking today about like hey if you're a
fat you can't look at everyone like hey
this person Chester alright and if we
add to be like okay that goes not a bad
person
yeah just mentally weak right now a
little just deal with it
don't drink that drink jock a white tea
which actually tastes better than coke
there's no doubt but it tastes better
than coke subjective but are you serious
right now I'm saying better as a subject
yeah that everyone agrees with in the
world put it side-by-side taste test
there you go will go boom guarantee
everybody cares give me that give me
that give me the jock a white tea they
don't want that
it's syrup sugar I think you might be
hundred forty seven percent Kirk I know
absolutely will do a taste test only you
can taste the coke because I'm not I'm
not touching my lips to that stuff
yes the minute one time they had a we
have a PT situation we called a monster
mash sure and it's you just do a bunch
of crazy events as we pull ups and rope
climbs carry boats around and swim and
we're doing it when I was the oh I the
officer in charge of trade net and so
yeah oh I see trade so I brought my son
with me mmm and a dead did this monster
mash and
one of the things you had to do in the
Monster Mash this thing's being timed in
serration all know something you had to
drink a full coca-cola through a straw
oh my son's doing the monster machine
he's probably 7 or something like that
and he'd never even had a coke before we
burned his mouth really yeah and he just
hated it
yeah yeah nasty to him yeah that's how I
looked at you the other back-kick look
good you're making me sick so I'll go
white tea
you know go on there read the reviews as
well you know you'll see things like
this excellent tea when I need to crush
and power through all the work I brew be
some choco white tea if I need a little
extra kick to crush it that's what I do
I begun working fewer hours at the
office as my productivity has risen 900
percent that's pretty legit actual
numbers yeah yeah and obviously that's a
100% accurate because it came from an
Amazon review so and and actually
there's a warning as well caution
regarding this product leaving your
supply of Java white tea out in the open
will require overwatch I now have non
tea drinkers hitting my reserves almost
as badly as dedicated tea drinkers no
double-blind study required right that's
this is the thing it doesn't taste like
tea right it doesn't taste like tea in
my opinion it tastes like piss like
victory but it doesn't make it so that's
that jaw collection get it on amazon.com
way to war your kid the book isn't out
as you know thank you for getting it
kids have been crushing it it's awesome
that's one of my favorite things that
has happened to me in the past mid
several years is people started posting
pictures of their kids reading way the
warrior kid yeah and that was awesome
for me to see and I'll tell you why it
was awesome because I know I know those
kids are reading that book and they're
thinking that they're going to get a
little bit better than a little bit
stronger a little bit faster and a
little bit smarter and they're guys and
people are sending me pictures of kids
doing push-ups and kids doing a guy's
sent me a video
of his kid you know how you have little
night vision in your kid's room so you
can monitor them Oh like on the little
monitor yeah little monitor only sent me
a picture a video of the monitor the
kids in a room after nighttime after
said guess what the kids doing push up
you doing push-ups why I wants to get
stronger wants to get better so yeah get
that if you got kids get it from if
you're an adult that's cool get it
anyways adults have a lot to learn from
Uncle Jake myself included so run out go
to your local book store and grab copies
if they don't have it in your local book
store just tell them to get it so that
other kids can see it and get it let's
make people better
also you can pre-order discipline equals
freedom Field Manual again that you can
find it in the get after it section of
any bookstore or online bookseller it is
the only book in that section if your
bookstore doesn't have that section what
you probably won't tell them to get
after it and make one and then put this
one equals freedom there and copy of it
for yourself
extreme ownership yes the fundamental
principles of combat leadership they
will help you win in any capacity on the
battlefield on the beat in business in
life extreme ownership written by myself
and my brother lathe davon you can get
that book as well if you need more than
the podcast and the book that's fine ok
contact the leadership and management
consulting company a chillon front info
at echelon front calm now the muster the
muster we just got done with mustard
0:02 in New York City what's your
assessment psycho trust my system it was
that it it was an upgrade it is it was
an upgrade from the first one and that's
saying a lot because that first one was
good I was like dang that was really
impactful to the handler and I don't
really say like oh this event was
impactful I don't use that word not
because I'm above enough like that but
I'm just saying to say they got to be
fro so that first one was
yes this is really good from top to
bottom like even K the material booms
like all usable material all of it and
then like I always say and I think
people overlook this part a lot of time
like just the social element it's so
easy to make friends with everyone
because they all kind of have the same
kind of interesting goals in one way or
another there's going to be some overlap
there logistic part was fun too you know
it's like just a great event you know
and then the second one and I wasn't I'm
be honest with you I wasn't as fired up
because it was in New York it's like
outside of the comfort zone the first
one here san Diego's like cool sweet I
was like he was even better that's that
this past one was better yeah it was
good getting great feedback awesome and
like you said I think the important what
one of the most important things you
just said it's very pragmatic yeah it's
not like it's not like hey you're going
to learn some stuff but it's not going
to be really applicable no no no it's
gonna be applicable yeah you walk out
when you finish that section and we get
done talking about it
boom you can even implement that
immediately yeah it's interesting you
guys have like a lot of military stories
and examples you know and then but when
you go to the QA like all the people
with their questions not one of them is
military they're all work maybe
relationship maybe here and there but
it's like at work you know like I do
yeah and exactly in every one of those
situations we answer I'd say we answer
with both business examples that we've
experienced and military examples but
yeah you you absolutely we've seen this
is the thing we've seen it happened for
whatever that little issue is that
you're having yeah seen it before you
know I've seen before I've seen
something like it we'll be able to find
an answer come to a conclusion and move
forward with the techniques the
principles that we talk about extreme
leadership but it's like this extreme
ownership the book is an awesome way to
get the fundamental principles but when
you come to the event now you can really
personalize it you know you can really
make sense of it it's just like learning
jujitsu like it's cool yeah watch the
YouTube videos yeah also go to class
also go to the seminar learn it from as
many different angles as you can because
the more angles you learn it from the
better you the more proficient you'll be
at applying them to your world yeah and
the
yeah and that's not you know you talk
about jiu-jitsu another cool part about
it is you know teach the jujitsu on the
last day like you can come and actually
like rope we'll try to chill Jocko yeah
come and bring it you did good cool you
don't come think about it most times
like if you go to like a you know oh
yeah I can go try to choke the guy at
the end of it you can't say like um hey
I'm gonna go see this concert and then
afterwards I'm gonna pick up guitar and
yeah you know the solos with yeah Eric
Clapton yeah exactly right that doesn't
happen and as you can yeah and this is
like like actually choking up the person
you know that's like an added element
you know I mean I got your roles like
plenty of the guys and it's just so cool
to be like oh yeah you know we talking
we talk about this and then get it on a
stress you know and this is so anyways
if you didn't make it in New York City
which was awesome Times Square we had a
great time the next one we're having
July 13th and 14th in Austin Texas the
Omni Barton Creek Resort & Spa
now this is one thing that it just is
what it is
in New York we we were planning to do
like 350 people and then we sold that
out we opened it up for another 50 and
we and we and we had to expand our room
to get that and then that sold out and
so then we we rearranged the or the
situation in there to get more people in
there it looks like in Austin we're
capped but we can't get any bigger than
the room that we've got and so it's 350
so if you want to come sign up quick
before it gets sold out because there's
no way we can expand it into more people
so just be aware of that if you can't
make that for 13th and 14th of July 13th
and 14th in Austin Texas San Diego
California September 14th and 15th we're
back in San Diego for follow-on
operations so come and get it while
you're waiting for the muster if you
need to pass communications to myself or
echo Charles we can be found on the
interwebs Twitter Instagram plus
ah we on that Facebook e echo is at echo
Charles and I am at Jocko willing then
thanks to everyone for listening to the
podcast for sharing the podcast for
supporting the podcast we really do
appreciate it thanks the military
personnel out there that are protecting
our freedoms overseas and also the law
enforcement the firefighters EMTs first
responders that keep us safe here at
home thanks to you all and to everyone
for whatever your mission might be let's
think about dick winners personal quest
very simple to excel in everything he
did excel in everything he did we should
do the same excel in everything we do
from working - working out from the way
we treat people to the way we treat
ourselves Excel put forth your greatest
effort in everything you do from the
small seemingly meaningless tasks to the
big goals as you attack those goals or
as those goals start to grind you down
remember the oppressive pure determined
effort that dick winners taught us all
and go out there and get after it
so until next time this is echo and
Jocko out